how to leave
5 11.
what about you so wrong six two oh okay
you're just a little bit shorter that's
good excuse me I said you registered a
bit shorter
in the garage yeah it's fine it's fine
I've got I've got ammo don't worry about
it oh it's not ammo I just if it isn't
it yeah it's a pleasant surprise when
people think you're short for my height
six is definitely tall whereas
Castillo's the opposite everyone thinks
he's like oh yes
I feel like I'm installing him still I
have to bend over a little he's five
seven you know oh yeah I think he
started I think we're gonna record in
already
okay okay
what up guys and welcome back to the
gray area with myself Sarah Garvey and
the woman who is currently carpet
bombing the internet right now you see
here with everywhere both on Tick Tock
you see her on YouTube you see her on
Twitter she's all over the place
just pearly things thank you Sarah they
can't they tried to take my Tick Tock
away but you can't get rid of me baby
and count number four where we're about
to hit 100K on account number four in a
week then get rid of me
yeah because they took away account
number one two and three so now count
number four I am on my one of my last
strikes on account number four so I I
might have to start again we'll see damn
right so today's show today's show is
do modern women want cats or dogs I
think dogs you think dogs yeah I think
dogs
um because loneliness is coming for them
no
um wow the wall is undefeated as this as
Kevin Samuel said
um but before we get started do you like
can see that we have you know some
guests with us so
let's introduce our guests you want to
go around as a matter of fact Pearl what
do you want to let the people know
because yeah I got I got some I got some
announcements sorry yeah I'm sorry sorry
I was about to get in yeah don't he got
too excited I tried to try to cut you
off I'll let it I'll let it slide this
time sorry sorry I've got no more places
if it happens again
so I guess video
don't subscribe we have beef um I know
this isn't live but I'm hoping we're
gonna get solid internet by the end of
the week so um tune in Saturday
hopefully for our first live show back
um on top of that we have two clips
channels if you guys want to follow it's
a pearl just pearly clips and pearl
daily we give different editors
different like that have different
editing Styles just to give you guys
variety when it comes to the clips
channels
on top of that we have three no no we
have four member tiers we have the five
dollar tier if you want to be a part of
the members only chat ten dollar tier
guys this this Penthouse is cool right
if you guys want to see a first behind
the scenes look of the penthouse sign up
for the ten dollar tier we have our
Vlogs on that tier
um tier three you can connect with us on
social media tier four you get a
one-on-one call with us once a month
um on top of that our member of the week
is Dragon
stallion1001 we have a Members Only Live
I'm assuming we have internet in two
weeks and if you want to come on the
show DM Eddie follow my Instagram
just.pearlythings and my new tick tock
account
um just pearlythings.4
yeah and just pearly things five because
I'm kind of nervous they're going to
take away for us
oh I think
squirrel a whale but to be fair she
called me a slag first I I one okay
that's fair enough one of us one of us
spoke facts yeah
and I would do this if anything I should
apologize to the whales in the ocean
that's a beautiful Majestic creature
let's get started on this show
um let's go around and could you all
just introduce yourselves please we
should start over here so my name is
denalva
um I work in community empowerment and I
heard what Sarah had to say about a lot
of things and I thought this would be a
good opportunity for me to maybe try and
you know re-educate people into what a
modern woman actually looks like in a
good way okay tell us a fun fact about
yourself
I speak four languages nice okay next
uh my name is Angel I do influencing on
Instagram I'm also a chef and I sing as
well and
um yeah if you want to follow my
Instagram follow my life as angel8
I'm Imogen I work for a medicines agency
as a research analyst I'm also a singer
and I cook as well but I'm not quite as
qualified as this one yet but okay
hello my name is Linda
um and I don't want to get fired from my
woke job hence the mask and the shades
it's not a political statement No
Worries
go on
uh my name is Brandon I'm just a guy
chasing my dreams
right
straight to the point so um ladies and
gents
um we're going to start off with an
article from the guardian okay I'm gonna
read this article and it says this the
office for National statistics shows
that women not living in a couple who
have never been married is rising in
every aimed rage under under 70. in the
in in the decade and a half between
2002 sorry to 2018 the figure for those
aged 40 to 70 year olds by half a
million the percentage of never married
Singletons in their 40s doubled there is
no avoiding that our romantic
opportunities have dwindled as the poor
of age-appropriate men has been emptied
this is what a woman's now saying
annually we manage a small smattering
updates between us most of us have grown
wary of online dating which requires you
to treat it as an all-consuming hobby or
a part-time job we are tired of Tinder
bored of bumble I have been ejected by
eHarmony which I last time last time I
logged on you told me I could they could
not find me a single match
ouch oh they couldn't find her a single
match what a lady in the guardian said
to you they were interviewing her I
wonder what she looks like yeah how much
she weigh she's probably a whale yeah
she's probably a whale
so ladies what do we think what do we
think of the dating scene right now and
our modern women becoming more lonely
okay I was in a five-year relationship
which means I was 23 when I got into it
and I was 28 when I came out I'm not 29.
when I came out I decided to join hinge
and Tinder because I was dealing with 24
25 year old men and now I'm dealing with
men that plus 30 plus so I want to know
what the new kind of pool of dating
feels like and to be honest
it's not good I feel like people are too
focus on the The Superficial they don't
go deep enough and that's why people
don't trust each other it's not just
because women are turning bad it goes
both ways so yeah it's messed up right
now for real I agree with that
yeah I've never been to any uh dating
sites and everything and every time I
date someone I have to meet them face to
face like you know from friends to
friends and like All My Exes I never
found them like any social media or um
you know I mean probably yeah not social
media but it's more more likely like
I've met them in real life instead of
actually being on a dating app and
everything our stories are quite similar
meandanova so I was also in a
relationship for five years and I've
never been the same as Angel I've never
been on a dating website and when that
relationship ended I didn't think to go
straight to a dating website I just
stepped outside I did it for research
purposes by the way
do you think I have problems finding a
man
is long
come on it's just way in okay
okay it's very um
we live in a world with social media and
we live in a world with a lot of
distractions and I think people are
under the illusion that people are
replaceable and are very much addicted
to the dopamine hit of meeting someone
new and the infatuation but the minute
it gets difficult oh well there's
someone I can swipe on Tinder and they'd
want to go out with me kind of thing and
I think also too in in in society I
think men have they know what women want
they know what women need and I don't
think it's the other way around
I would agree with that so you would say
that men know what women want but women
don't know what men want yeah
yeah
um you are perfect just the way you are
and you don't need to settle for anyone
less than you deserve and so I think and
so I think it leads people astray and
the question is what do you deserve you
deserve what you get and that's
something we don't tell women I think I
do you deserve it I think you deserve
like
someone on your level and I think I
think women with social media and stuff
if you if you like post a picture with
your butt out or even if you just post a
Photoshop photo or just a photo of
yourself and your Instagram is public
you can get thousands sorry I mean I
mean get like commitment wise oh like so
I'm saying like girls deserve what they
can get commitment wise but if I say I
deserve to be a millionaire and I don't
get millionaire outcomes that I probably
don't deserve to be a millionaire yeah
that's to you Bob that's why as well
what that's too far as well to be able
to oh yeah this is that much but like I
feel like most women just want
um a lot of respect as well from their
partner more like and you know get um
you know gestures and all these romantic
things when you're in a relationship
what I'm talking about and I feel like
nowadays it's really hard to find
a man that would do that because of how
the world is at the moment you know our
generation that's just you know as what
you said social media and all these
things it just distract a lot of man
fully because they like a lot of men
follow women on Instagram because
obviously they find these females
attractive and all these things and that
kind of messes up how they think about
females too so when they're trying to
um when they trying to uh I don't know
if a girl if they're dating are females
if they're dating a girl it's really
hard for them to like focus on that one
person because there's so many things on
social media that's only I would say
that's only a small percentage of men
because most men don't have the options
to focus on other girls
so like like on um dating apps women
only swipe right five percent of the
time where men swipe right fifty percent
of the time
and like one one out of one out of three
minutes one on one out of three men are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year yeah so so those you're saying
like those guys like they're not you
would be the center of their world but
we don't want those guys like for
example if you want a guy that's over
six foot you know I'm looking at my tall
you know yeah which same but but that's
only 15 of men and if you want to be
good looking cut that in half if you
want to make money cut that in half if
you want and if you want if you want
them to have a similar personality like
charismatic cut that in half so that's
it's like two percent of guys we're all
fighting over so then do you see why do
you see why I'm asking the question do
modern women want cats or dogs because
you're gonna be lonely because if you if
you are fighting in a pool of men
that only a certain amount there's only
a certain amount of those top tier men
that women want but 80 of women
generally list 20 of men when they ask
for their ideal men right so if there's
20 of men who have an 80 pool of women
to choose from that will leave at least
what 60 of women without a partner
however those women continue to fight
for that top 20 man and that's one of
the reasons why a lot of women say men
are trash men are dogs men are this
because they are fighting for the same
men well and half of those guys don't
commit to anyone why would you why why
would you if you have that many options
like Drake was Drake gonna get a wife no
but I think it goes back to what you
were saying about how the women even
know what they want anyway in the first
no no it's that's not what I said I said
do women know what men want okay oh we
want to know that's a good question
because it's instilled in men go get a
job make sure you can
as much resources
so that you can find
looking woman or best woman you can but
like a lot of women don't know what
genuinely satisfies a man I know in my
experience in the past I just thought
like I was told to date who I want to be
and that's exactly the exact opposite in
reality Brandon what do you think
um the day in community
well when it comes to like social media
dating
that [ __ ] ain't real because let's keep
our buck majority of female just dating
for attention male attention so that's
why a lot of females don't meet guys on
social media day like I'm telling you
you get the guys that's on day and
strictly because they want to [ __ ] let's
keep a 100 like they Wanna [ __ ] because
the average dude is actually lonely he's
like invisible to society so he's
swiping like he's like his his life to
be like his life is actually dependent
on this [ __ ] so I've been thinking just
any girl just come my way swipe right so
I can meet you because they strictly
just want to have sex but for me the
online dating is just rigged now so like
like the actual article said and like
you know Pearl says a lot on on the show
and I say a lot
um
single women over 30 50 of single women
over 30 are childless right what what
have they got going on they they're
basically walking into loneliness can I
just say something quickly I find it
really alarming that when we're speaking
about men we can break it into
percentages when we speak about women's
is the majority of no there's a lot of
women out there actually and I speak
from personal experience that are fit to
be wives right now but they're also the
same way that women are picking certain
percentages that one percent of men is
the same way that men are looking for
that one percent of women they want a
woman that cooks a woman that is has a
job and that there's all these amazing
things which is great but actually
there's a lot of women that all they can
do is do is clean but they'll take care
of you nicely a lot of men want a woman
that is absolutely beautiful and has the
body and has all of these things not all
women are like that that's why women are
also riddled with insecurity so I think
that's from your experience because you
you're pretty you're a pretty girl you
only deal with the top man the top men
are very selective but most men aren't
hence why they swipe right 50 of the
time on dating apps in one out of four
marriages are sexless I so so most men
really aren't that picky and even even
if we look at from a weight perspective
like most women are overweight and yet
men still accept it okay I'll I'll show
you another perspective even putting
aside the the I appreciate that thank
you for saying I'm free but putting that
aside is the fact that men are visual
which means that even the women that are
ready to be wives and the ones that they
should be taking as much as they should
be going for that one they still got
their eye on the big ones on the ones
that have the nice person
why do you think a lot of men cheat okay
let me let me ask you guys one to ten
how pretty do you need a wifey to be
a wife yeah why six six seven sixty
what's up yeah but remember women are
looking for the eights nines and tens
because we look for twenty percent of
guys so women are more picky than men
are and this is and this is just two two
guys at least one thing you need to
understand the most successful a guy is
the more he's gonna literally increase
the percentage like the average dude he
he don't matter if you're five that's
good as long as you're cooperative and
submissive he's good with that but
majority of females are not submissive
they carry this masculine energy about
them okay I think I think what what when
you when you were asking that question
Pearl right
um one of the things that a lot of women
don't understand about men is generally
we prefer a woman's character right so a
woman could be you know there's a thing
that says oh the pretty girls are crazy
or the you know the baddies are crazy
right for a long-term relationship
that's not sustainable okay so when
you're looking for a wife
you want a woman who is going to have
good character and a lot of the time
when women have only been shown and told
that their looks are the be all and end
all they haven't had time to work on
their character and so what it is is
that they just think pretty gets them
through the door and and I've said a lot
of women do not understand specifically
that when you have a vagina which you
have that's just not good enough
to sustain a relationship it's it's
really not and and if you think that
your vagina is going to sustain a
relationship and you haven't worked on
your character that man's gonna go
elsewhere of course I agree but then
again he goes back to the point that I
was trying to make we can say all of
that but at the end of the day women are
extremely insecure because the same way
we can say oh yeah a wife needs to be at
least a five but have a good character
you see a 10 walking down the street
you're going to be tempted that's just
men the hormones play funny games and
that's why a lot of men will have
beautiful amazing wives at home and
they're out there with side chicks and
that's not because the woman is not
submissive and doesn't know how to take
care of her man the same way we want to
you know crucify women now because it's
that time to put the you know the lens
on women we also need to look at the
fact that men are also not appreciate
enough to win that out there I listen I
was in a five-year relationship I have a
strong character but I know how to be a
wife I know how to make my man feel like
he's in control wait can I ask a
question though you said that you go
into a relationship when you're 23 right
yeah see the thing is statistically
women and are literally in their whole
phases from like 18 to 25 so even if
you're getting bagged when you're 23 in
reality you're trying to escape
because according to what the numbers
these times and this is what I say
there's no point in generalizing women
because I for my own personal experience
knowing myself even knowing these girls
sit next to me not every single woman is
wanting to escape the whole life because
if I wanted to be in whole life I would
do it okay so then why did your
relationship no you wouldn't do it my
relationship ended this is a funny
question because I love it when people
ask me this because they look at my
character and they think oh it must be
because the novel is you know uh
difficult to deal with no it's not I was
do you think you are no I'm actually
very easy going and this is the funniest
thing I'm a pretty girl now I grew up as
a tomboy so the boys have always been my
demand them I know how to deal with men
I know what men want I know how they
think I can get on with them the reason
why my relationship ended actually is
because I had a man that could not
actually be able to understand how I can
be all of these cool things and be
powerful in who I am he got jealous of
my light and he couldn't understand that
I could be powerful my femininity and
that's where can you elaborate when you
mean powerful in your femininity I'm an
educated woman I'm funny I'm pretty
and when women say I'm educated that's
when they think I should be the boss
I'll tell you why I tell you by me being
educated is important I've got three
degrees you know what that means it
doesn't actually mean that I have to
listen I'm so sorry wait wait let me
please don't mean [ __ ] they do mean a
lot they don't what's the degree what it
means it means hard work and
perseverance
I went from the US to the UK your
school's easy here I'm sorry I said it
easy it's okay it's easy depending on
how you do it because I was a first
class student because I work hard
because what I wanted was to prove to
myself that I can put myself into any
project see it through work hardly
maintain my life the way that it's meant
to be my degrees don't make me feel more
powerful than anybody my degree proof to
me that if I put my mind to something
and I work hard I get the results so I
know that I'm a Survivor I'm a warrior
I'm a soldier and that is something that
actually man should be very grateful to
have because that's the kind of woman
that will be able to support you when
you have a plan when you have a project
she'll be able to be there for you are
you now telling men what they're
supposed to
um value I'm telling men that they
should value actually a woman that can
help them if they're what was the end
tomorrow you would need a woman one
second that's the problem
I tell you what the problem is
um like
um Linda said right women don't know
what men want and the fact that you
think you can sit there and tell men
what they should actually want without
actually asking them what they actually
want is the problem okay I'll tell you
how I know this do you know what women
want oh we know what we want we've been
we've been told we've been told what
women wanted from day one you want to
protect her you want a provider right
right you want somebody who can be a
good father
right
um you want someone to support your
dreams if you have them right
did I did did I you want somebody who
listens you want a man who like we've
heard all of this as men like we've
heard it for like listeners
let me let me ask you guys what do you
think men want oh because I just I just
named five okay
men want uh somebody that can be a
support system without judgment that
means that when you come home and you're
having your man problems you can
actually come to somebody and be that
person that lays down and shows some
sort of vulnerability without being
judged because a man is a man bullet
point them bullet point one that's one
you want you want somebody that can be
caring but listening to without judgment
you want somebody you can trust okay two
you want somebody that is nurturing
because that person is going to be your
wife is going to be the mother of your
children and your Offspring obviously
they have to succeed in life and you
ideally so you'd want somebody that can
nurture that and create a home out of a
house and then third you probably want
someone that can actually satisfied not
probably definitely that was that
satisfies your needs sexually no no
listen where is the submission part
though wait I was waiting the submission
the submission comes from the part that
where the woman is supportive submission
doesn't actually mean the new one has to
be below a man a woman needs to be
supportive or his role yeah you know the
same way you manage to be supportive
you actually don't know well I think if
that's not what men want it's the same
way that women want certain things
men then should be considered as well
what they think women want because the
problem is that people don't feel I
don't feel like people understand what
the what a partnership or unionship
means between a man and a woman there's
a lack of understanding of what you're
actually meant to be doing together so
when I name those four or five things
was I generally right yeah kind of but
really when you just I don't know when
you just went on your rent do you think
you were generally right yes no you want
to leave my wife for sure and this is
the problem no because okay so you don't
you want to woman that you come home and
say you know baby okay so so the problem
so the problem is you you think you do
the problem is the problem is you speak
a lot but you don't listen that's the
problem and so when men speak and this
and this has been the problem for like a
long time
when men start speaking and telling you
exactly what they want women find
excuses as to not give the men what
they're actually asking for okay so when
men start saying what they want women
start saying oh that's misogynistic oh
that is um that that's patriarchy all of
these things that's what women start
saying but men have been the same from
day one men have generally not changed
friendly fit feminine friendly
about submissiveness so if you say that
um women react in that sort of way if
they don't and they just say yeah okay
I'm understanding what you want then
that's the submissiveness that you are
talking about isn't it really rather
than being yeah you're right you're
right because it's agreeable so like
disagreeable is a masculine masculine is
like for example though this woman I
heard about some some random [ __ ] you're
saying he's like they're married yeah
and the woman is like oh I don't want to
have sex every day this that this is my
body shut the [ __ ] up man when you're
when you get in a marriage I own you
[ __ ] you are my [ __ ] so when you're my
[ __ ] if I want to have sex if I came
home from a long day trying to provide
for you you're gonna open your legs and
I'm gonna yeah
literally that's lack of respect that
woman actually wants there's a
difference between what is one thing can
you edit it like that bro
for women
okay do you think sex is a duty in
marriage no that's why I said they want
the woman
pleasure okay okay so okay so no no yes
yes what about yeah yeah yes because I I
would say like if he's marrying you he's
protecting and providing why would you
not give him sex no I'm not saying like
we're not I'm not giving him sex it's
just like he shouldn't be a duty he
shouldn't be like him okay if you don't
if you don't know if it's you but you
can't force me on ownership but see that
that's like a lack of submission though
because because if you're submissive you
just say okay yeah whenever you want
because you're the one and you're in
charge like I also finished at work or
everything like that and he wants to
have
um you know okay do you do so do you
show up to your job when you don't feel
like it sorry do you show up to your job
when you don't feel like it yes being a
wife is a job that's your job just do it
because even when you don't feel like it
so may I ask a question then you're a
man you're a provider I want this so you
go get it for me because you're a man
you know what a woman wants to provide
that for me and that's it provide what
the moment you provide me what I want I
want a bigger house I want a bigger car
I want a job wait wait wait I'm actually
exactly and when they marry you okay you
are my man provide for me no I'm glad
you said that because that's what modern
women do um actually one of the number
one indicators that a woman is going to
leave is she starts to out on her man
and so and even when you're talking
about like education like or they out
educate their man like that's a very
similar story that I hear often so
you're actually kind of correct when
women do that constantly and so when a
man when a man has the same standard
it's somehow like women get mad exactly
so if that is the case then we can
complain about either side your provider
you do what the woman wants you a lot of
men will say that it's entitlement well
then if you're the money for a woman to
even have sex with you and even she's
not in the mouth men don't mind
providing for women that deserve it well
then a woman doesn't mind opening her
legs for man that deserves it if you act
right you'll get everything oh so while
you get into a relationship with someone
that don't deserve it then because you
don't always know who you're getting
okay
Linda gone I
think there's maybe a discrepancy of the
definition of submission I think you
guys have a perception of what they mean
by submission and I may have a different
one so can we kind of clarify what we
think submission yeah what do women
think submission is because it's
normally women that have a problem with
the word so what do you actually think
it is
um I think submission is understanding
somebody else's strengths so if you are
a man and you're telling me babe I need
to go and get this job and you're gonna
have to do this because this is the plan
and this is what you need to do I guess
I would submit in that in that position
because your planning is is what you do
best that's your skill that's what you
do if we're now in the house and you're
trying to tell me how is the best way
for us to spend money in the house when
I run the home then I'm not going to
submit to you trying to tell me that
because actually you need to respect my
role and I respect yours I believe
that's what submission is submission is
when you understand that in respect
somebody else's position being in that
situation specifically ahead of you do
you think do you think of yourself as a
submissive person listen I dated
Nigerian for five years I know what
submission is and yes I am submissive if
if it makes sense I don't submit just
for the sake of things and when things
don't make sense I actually am able to
communicate clearly and maturely enough
to explain why this doesn't make do you
think you give off submissive energy but
that's not the point well and this is
the thing what I feel like is my my
strength empowers a woman is actually a
filter that I feel gets the right people
around me because when you get to know
me you understand that this what I'm
doing is doing is to test people because
I need to know that the man that I'm
getting with is emotionally mature
enough to understand that I can be a
powerful woman but I can also be a
feminine woman that can take care of a
man and nurture him I can ask you a
question are you single I am okay that's
what no it's not you know why I'm single
because I was in abusive relationship
for five years and I finally decided to
leave and say actually you know what
this man I'm giving everything that I
can I become a robot for this person he
didn't value me did you did you file a
police report I never did because I
thought protecting him because I loved
him so why didn't you file when you left
I didn't fall because I don't need to
he's a black man I'd rather protect him
in that way and just walk away from the
situation and said you know what the
universe will deal with you I don't need
to perform but earlier on you said that
the reason why you're single is because
you are a powerful woman and he couldn't
um you couldn't like um help help your
dreams or whatever it is you said no no
and now and now you're saying you left
because he was August 20. so which one
is it I'll explain to you why the
situation go abusive when you're dealing
with somebody that wants to be in the
Starlight and wants to be you know the
Superstar if you have a certain energy
that calls for attention it becomes a
problem I know how to speak to people
people drawn to me and in a relationship
and as a woman that is also beautiful
that can look very bad sometimes so when
men come to speak to me when women come
to speak to me and I'm giving a lot of
attention it became a problem and you
know what sometimes I at the beginning I
was like okay it makes sense but after a
while after I tried the submission after
I fulfilled the role that you're meant
to fulfill especially because I was
dealing with the Nigeria with the
Nigerian that has very traditional value
special of what the role of woman is
meant to be I understood that that's not
good enough and that's actually what
um I understood is that at this point I
know the problem is no longer with me
because I tried everything I listened I
tried my self-awareness do you think a
lot actually a lot more than than what
people think I speak like this because I
feel like it's important for a woman to
actually be able to give as much power
as man does so that can re-educate
people to understand not all women are
the same not all women are going to be
lonely and not all women all women that
are single are the perpetrators
sometimes a woman is supposed to give as
much power as Amanda as what you just
said it's not that woman needs to give
as much power as a man that's that's
what you said though no a woman needs to
be able to give as much power but in her
own way I don't need to be sitting down
in a room and take measuring with men I
have my own power as a woman and what
power is that my power is about
femininity the power of being able to
speak intelligently but quite simply
without having to prove points all the
time yeah but men don't give a [ __ ] if
you're intelligent but the thing is I
don't they just care if you're kind of
submissive and you're nurturing let me
tell you something before I am with a
man I am myself if I have a career if I
have my own dreams in life I don't
expect to have to give all that up
because I have a home a man at home and
I have to be submissive I am powerful in
who I am but I can also be a woman that
is in a relationship and can be happy I
don't need to be showing my power and
deep measuring with my husband that's
cheap so let's say for example you get
if a guy that's a one percent maybe
Draco feature one or any of that and he
said I want you to quit your job are you
going to quit your job
the thing is if he provides it depends
on the alternative it depends on the
alternative answer the question it
depends on the alternative I can't just
tell you because future and Drake what
they're going to offer okay
maybe mother maybe mother drama maybe
a little drama if he says to me babe
listen this is a guy that you want to be
with he has the quote like this is the
guy I don't know what the guy is to you
but like we don't need to make it
complicated it's not future it's not
Drake it's just a whatever your dream
guy is he says quit your job yes or no
I'll be like what do you want me to do
then because I'll get bored at home I'm
not gonna lie
do you know what's so funny is that you
think you're submissive it's amazing
you're a masculine wants a guy to be on
your own terms
let me just explain it to you okay
because that's your boss like submission
is looking at that man like he is your
boss and so but that that's because
you're not submissive like I Googled the
definition of submissive it's the action
of accepting or yielding to a superior
Air Force or to the will or authority of
another person so it's you're giving the
man authority to tell you to quit your
job but not over everything that's the
whole point it needs to be selective
because that's but okay that's that's
that's not submission that's the problem
but you want the total submission with
total submission does not make sense
because it's not every single time that
a man's decision to tell you to do
something is going to be right the
moment you start accepting to be
submissive over things that don't make
sense you're going to lose yourself yeah
but the things that don't make sense you
don't have to do that but the stuff that
do make sense so you're telling me to
quit my job without giving me an
alternative of what I'm gonna do it
doesn't make sense
this is how how it would be okay it's
it's trusting his judgment so you saying
oh well it depends on all these factors
that submission is saying you know what
I know you're a good man I picked you I
trust your judgment you pick your boss
okay who you're gonna submit to so but
when you're coming in and saying well I
need to know all the details that's not
submissive it's not if a man says to you
right listen at eight o'clock I'm coming
to pick you up put on your best dress
and your best shoes don't worry about it
I got you what are you gonna do cool so
when are you gonna be like yeah but
where are we going no what are we doing
who are we going to be with us
that's what it sounds like you're going
to give yourself hang on one second one
second because that's no different
because this is this is the thing
because when a man does that he's he's
actually doing it to see what you're
like because if if I can tell you listen
eight o'clock put your best dress on
your best shoes don't worry about it and
you say okay baby
I love that [ __ ] but going on a date and
quitting your job is totally different
no not really even putting it in the
same submission you tell me babe quit
your job and I said to you babe
was the alternative and he said to me
listen don't worry trust me okay you
know you see what I mean because women
the same way that a woman
reassurement because women want
stability as well that's one of the
things that women also want stability
because the future for a woman who is
going to be a mother and all of these
things requires a lot of stability so
you as the provider the protective I say
to you what's the alternative you tell
me don't worry babe trust me I got you
then the story is different okay if you
expect me to quit like this because you
told me to that's wrong okay so but now
you're switching it you're saying okay
I'll submit when you talk to me the way
I like to be taught no like listen when
a woman when a woman you could say no
but that's what you said when a woman
says to you the same way that he said to
you that when you ask you these
questions is to see what you like when a
woman asks you certain questions she
doesn't really want an answer she wants
reassurance the same word that she says
babe do I look nice you don't need to
tell her yeah I like your hair like
there's no baby you're beautiful that's
all she wants to hear if I'm asking you
what you'll ask me to quit my job what
am I gonna do you say babe don't worry I
got you that's reassurance then I'm more
likely to do it because he confidently
told me that he has my best interests at
heart and that he's got my back so I'm
not going into blind what do you mean
your best interest because if he loves
me he's supposed to have my best
interest at heart and if I ask him a
question like this anytime baby don't
worry I got you then I know that you
love me can I ask you a question see
yeah let's say for example your marrying
a guy that's ambitious both of you are
building together you see if you're with
an ambitious guy one of you guys are
gonna have to give up your dream to your
job to support the other
so if you're not going to do that it
means you're not a submissive woman
because a submissive woman is going to
support that guy until he makes it and
then yeah the guy is definitely going to
bring you up when he's there but if you
can't do that that means you're not a
submissive woman how am I not supporting
my mind but I still do you think that do
you really think that used to support
somebody you have to give up on
everything yes if you have a kid you
have to give up on a lot of stuff no no
I'll give you I'll give you an example
I'll give you so my dad's a top one
percent earner top top one percent it's
probably half a percent actually he's
very successful and my mom was a teacher
she was going to college and she was
dating him they were doing distance and
he said you can transfer schools and be
with me or you can find a new boyfriend
she transferred to be with him then she
started a business he started business
she was teaching she was a teacher she
taught first grade he said okay
um I I need help with the business quit
she quit she got a top one percent guy
she got 10 kids
lives in like five houses but she
wouldn't have gotten that if she wasn't
submissive and so she said well but it
all depends
I'm telling you this is how you say it
like this is
no no she was seriously he was broke
with a ton of college debts no but I
mean the connection the love between
them yeah but seriously I don't it was
what's your name again
seriously I really don't think you
understand how you sound I don't I
really don't I think you think you sound
a certain way
but you're not the way you're telling
people that you are okay I'll explain
something to you a bit differently the
way I'm explaining things to you now is
because we're going into detail when
we're talking about the actual
interaction this is now we're going this
is almost like I'm trying to educate
people with the behind the scenes if my
man because I've done this I was in a
relationship for five years I gave up a
lot to support somebody's dream I even
went as far as learning how to do Sound
Engineering because my boyfriend went to
be a rapper I went as far as that
because I wanted to support my man I
know is he a rapper that we know no not
really so you supported some I support
but I'm dead right no but guess what but
guess what and this is the beautiful
thing
no they've still done it
I still did it to support my man I still
went above and beyond to learn a new
skill to support his dream that's the
whole point and even with all of this
and no matter how much I tried it was
not valid so what I'm trying to say is
that submission is in we need to
actually really clear it out and
understand that submission is not said
pick up and drop everything because I
told you so submission comes on comes
through trust comes through respect it
comes through love but this is what
happens as a girl submits to the wrong
guy and that she doesn't want to offer
the same the same submission to the next
guy so it's like you submit to the wrong
guy I know the next guy has to pay for
it and that's why it is
sorry I was just going to say that's why
in your parents situation it works out
well for the best because obviously that
happened she made her decision and it
lasted but if it didn't and it went
South with your dad then well but that's
the thing like like ah it might have
changed you as a person for the future
for the next person well it just worked
out well so that's why I say that she
must have known in the first place
um the connection well because she she
wasn't going after a lot of The
Superficial things that a lot of like
women go after nowadays and like no I
mean I don't know your boyfriend but
like a rapper I mean do they make the
best buzzing and guess boyfriend like
just let's just wait a business
yeah
I don't I don't I don't know who he was
I don't know you personally but this is
just a try like I do this all the time I
talk to women four days a week and this
is a trend I see as they submit to the
rapper guy and then he treats them bad
and then they say oh no I can't trust
men the next guy I need to put up all
these walls I need to make him wait to
have sex I need to make him do this do
this do this and this is the good man
that would actually marry you so the
problem is really the problem is who you
choose as women that is the problem is
you are choosing wrong as women you are
attracted to the wrong things and you
are choosing the wrong types of men and
then what happens is when it goes south
based on your decisions by the way not
the man's decisions or not other men's
decisions who aren't your man when it
goes south what you are trying to do is
make the next man pay for something that
he didn't actually do and so what it is
is that you need to learn to choose
better men from the get-go I do agree
with that kind of but not really because
you know what the craziest thing is
nowadays this is why I say being
submissive is also another problem
because when you submissive in the Name
of Love and I'll tell you something he
wasn't just a rapper when I met him it
wasn't because he was a rapper actually
I mean even I met him in person through
family friends it was amazing he was an
amazing person and then he had the dream
of wanting to be a rapper and that's how
I supported him his dream right and I
generally I thought oh wow this person's
amazing he just switched on me and this
is the thing I am not and you did
nothing out of the blue
when it comes to when it comes to um
it's not that didn't do anything but
there's there's your character is shown
in certain situations you've got a
choice to make you can abuse somebody or
you can leave how many years in did you
see the red flag maybe like first second
year so and then you stayed for three or
four yes and is that on you a little bit
because it's accountability but this is
being a psychologist you kind of you you
understand a little bit more about being
a victim of abuse it's not always that
you're consciously making the decision
to stay because you're dumb and you know
no better you get to a point where
you're insecure and you're depressed and
gets to that stage and this is what I
say about being submissive to a man you
need to ensure that there's trust
respect and there's love because those
three things will make submission make
sense otherwise if you're just teaching
people to women to be submissive all the
time but you submit it to the wrong man
exactly let me tell you what it what the
problem is because I believed that for
you to be in a successful relationship
you have to be submissive so as a woman
I was submissive to the wrong person I
fell into a trap and this is what I'm
trying to say things need to make sense
it's not just about submit as a woman
you need to create and build a
relationship based on mutual respect
that's the only way submission makes
sense
because you also miss you you'll submit
into like bad boys because that's what
majority of females are attracted to so
if you're submissive to bad boys and the
good guy comes you're not going to be
submit you're going to give him
masculine energy before he was a bad boy
he was a good boy
you submitted one to two years in so the
majority of the relationship you knew he
was is a bad boy and you submitted so so
that's what I'm saying he's correct what
he's saying is based on he's he is
because it's based off the words that
came out of your mouth so okay I'll go
back in that spring okay so I submitted
for one year by then I'm in love and I'm
where I think we're gonna get married
you at the end of my life okay your two
things start to go a bit South year
three I'm thinking wow this is not
really great what year was he a rapper
was he a rapper all of these like
probably from year year one towards okay
so so I'll I'll give you I'll give you
something I'm I'm sorry to stop you so
when so when he's rapping what type of
lyrics are coming out of his mouth
actually and this is the thing he's
talented he didn't talk no no but he's
quite woke no I believe listen to what
I'm asking you right when he's rapping
is he talking about [ __ ] money blah
blah blah all this kind of stuff no no
and this is this is why I'm saying I
supported him also because it made sense
so he was it was like a Will Smith he's
good he's quite woke he said he was
extremely talented and he said things in
a way that I appreciate there was value
in these lyrics and this is what I'm
saying they said me she submit to make
you fall in love and then he gets to a
point where he's like now are these
people think commitment is rubbish
people don't commit I thought actually I
need to commit I've made my choice I've
found somebody that I do love although
things are not right I've already
submitted I'm here and I need to commit
otherwise probably I'll end up lonely
and have the feel of the being 13 being
childless and I was in a bad situation
with a dog or a cat which one do you
prefer fish they're prettier and easier
fish yeah I'll be outside it's some kind
of pet some kind of pet or maybe not
have a pet like you know bearded dragon
I'll probably have a baby what's a
bearded dragon
like an iguana yeah but a smaller one is
really cute I mean people are scared but
so do you sorry to switch it day do you
think women nowadays understand what it
is to be in a long-term relationship and
hold down a relationship
do you think women understand what that
is there's a lot of commitment sorry
Linda's right Linda's shaking head sorry
gone Linda no I I don't think they do
because I don't think it's it's in it's
distilled instilled in them
um I just feel as though they put a lot
of emphasis on the physical and I think
if you're dating to get married there
are certain things that you need to
agree upon and I don't think
in my experience with a lot of girls
that I talk to that call me about boy
advice and such I ask what are your
values what it what do you believe in
what are your political what are your
religious if you're religious do you
want does he want kids where do you
where do you want to live in the city do
you want to live in the the sub the
suburbs the countryside they don't know
these things about themselves so how can
you or and even guys too like how can
you how can you date if you don't have
common ground on those things can I ask
you a question how many women are here
there's like there's four of us and we
keep talking about women as if like ask
me if I know what I want I'll tell you
exactly where I want to live oh we can
definitely tell them you would
definitely tell us you know I'm just
saying I can tell you because obviously
I like to speak like this it's fun I
like being fiery fine but I'm sure Angel
knows I'm sure images I'm sure you know
not every single woman okay so what is
it what does it take to be in a long
what do you think it takes to be in a
long-term relationship or hold it down I
think number one 100 your intentions I
think when you meet somebody for the
first time number one normalize dating
for marriage because there's two
completely separate worlds out there
there's dating for marriage and there's
dating uh the Modern Woman yeah the
Modern Man internet dating meeting just
to have sex so let's put that to the
side if you're trying to date somebody
to be with them forever then it's about
your intentions so number one intentions
number two make sure you're compatible
if you're not I always say if I'm dating
somebody then if I'm not going to be
with them for the rest of my life then
why am I going to be dating them if it's
not working and we've discussed things
then I don't need to just be dating you
for no reason so that's it really for me
I think if you're the right person in a
partnership and it's going to work then
it's going to work and then you can hold
it down together and it moves into a
separate conversation about what what
more do you need but I think that very
first basis your best friend you need to
be best friends have the good intentions
together and be compatible and then from
then on everything else you build on
with your partner
[Music]
I feel like I totally agree and you need
to I feel like you just have to like
yeah just what you said best friends
because like without if you're just in a
relationship with this person and you're
not like
you know like close in some sort of ways
like as close friends or anything like
that it's I don't think it's gonna ever
work if it's just sex and all these
things and then yeah I just think that
you should be close I think it's a
massive generation thing that's
different as well like if you look at
you know our parents grandparents it's
completely different completely
different so earlier on when I was
asking you whether or not you know what
a man wants
um it's my opinion that when it comes to
relationships
everything that happens in a
relationship
for a woman is about her happiness right
and everything in a relationship that a
man does is for the woman's happiness it
should be for a man's happiness as well
so what so what is when does the man's
happiness come into play Because when
women talk about relationships we talk
about a lot about what they want right
and what they want from relationship and
I rarely hear women talk about what they
think they should give their man in a
relationship to make him happy I
completely disagree with that and I feel
like who are you talking to I do so
basically I'll give you guys an example
just just from this conversation when I
said do you think that sex is a duty
that's like the number one thing for you
guys Duty like they get it whenever they
want and then two of you but okay okay
but this is the thing like a lot of
times I call it out and then girls try
to change what they said or change what
they meant but like you said no you said
no you said yes so I'm saying and I'm
saying like that's what men want yeah
they want it to be a duty they want like
if you told a guy I can get married and
I get sex sometimes when she feels like
it no but this is the thing the we
opposed what he said because behind
everything one of the most important
things is always going to be the
intention when you go in with to do
something with a certain intention yes
it works if you're my husband and you
respect me and you love me and you come
home and I'm not in the mood but you're
like baby kiss me and you you you get
you you work now he doesn't he doesn't
kiss you he doesn't he says he says I
wanna I've had a long day let's [ __ ] and
you say I'm not in the mood well I
probably be like babe you know I'm not
in the mood to [ __ ] I'll give you a
[ __ ]
yeah you get creative like you as I feel
like this is the thing I will now go on
the other side of things and I'll
explain a lot of the time women don't
think about an alternative that can be
almost a satisfactory what as what they
are looking for because it's not all the
time that we're in the mood sometimes we
have periods not only that there's also
a lot of beautiful women out there the
Temptation is out there you got to put
yourself in front of then you got to get
creative that's all it is creativity to
keep your mind sexually excited and
interested is a must I think for real do
you ladies think that
women are generally lonely now because
we know without the hookup culture
because yes people are just like having
sex for for the sake of having sex like
do you think like women are lonely
nowadays a little bit because they're
scared a lot of the time a lot of girls
especially even like some of my friends
they'll have sex with a guy and they'll
be attached to that guy quite quickly
because an emotional thing and then the
guy is really not interested he's out
there to just hanging bad things so then
she's obviously going to be a bit upset
and then she gets upset and scared and
fearful of what's against those
situations
I don't think I don't think that well I
don't think any girl that goes to
Castillo looking for love is thinking
straight like you go but he gets girls
why do you think exactly because like
this is what I'm saying he there's
there's girls there's different type
there's different types of girls there's
girls and there's women there's boys and
there's men don't do that and then it's
true that's like the no true Scotsman
you talked about rappers rappers in in
how you were it's like saying oh a real
man would do that
even the
girl rotation she seemed like a nice
lady in the video if you know you know
I'm like what what did you expect like
what do you expect come on and that's
what I'm saying like when you even
talked about me being with a rapper I'm
sorry um this is why sorry you were
saying that you think they're lonely why
why do you think women are lonely mainly
a lot of fear and also I feel like women
feel like they need to give everything
to men so they might act in a certain
way and they might put on a front they
might just try and be that girl that I
love pressure yeah and then when it
comes down to the man isn't very
interested or they realize am I putting
on a facade and I'm not really being
myself they start thinking oh am I going
to be ending up like 40 and alone or
being a fake version of myself or
something
you see the truth is I think
good goals they don't get lonely but
modern females they are lonely because
they have this delusional ideology and
yes they may sleep around with the bad
boys stuff like that but they they will
soon realize the bad boys don't even
like you he only likes what's between
your legs and you guys may try to bag
him get in a relationship but he don't
want that commitment so literally when
you guys come across the nice guys you
guys don't want them so it's like you
guys don't want no trust me
I do modeling and stuff and I meet a lot
of also rappers and things like that
I've never ever dated one even if they
try and because I just know how they're
like and I'm not saying I know every
single how men thinks but like I know in
the industry I would even football is
like are you are you single no okay so
oh okay you you're you're attached okay
so you actually back it up your
boyfriend's nice yes he is nice but
there's
nothing what does he do
and I'm not perfect
that don't make sense so have you had a
relationship before a long-term
relationship no okay so do you know what
a woman wants yes why are you single
then why am I single yes am I single
well it's complicated I don't know
that's why I'm asking you don't need to
know oh okay but you want to be able to
know us and judge hours but we can't
actually look at things on your side and
actually put it on a perspective to say
actually let's look at men for a second
because we can crucify women but let's
see also because he goes two ways he
takes two to tango that's real I can oh
I can be accountable for my mistakes but
it's not all me nah listen this women
are not accountable
men and women are measured by different
standards men are measured by if they
can get laid not a relationship it's not
like a badge of honor to get a
girlfriend anyone can get a girlfriend
well you know some but but for women
we're measured by if we can attain a
relationship men are measured if by if
they can get laid Yeah because men some
men can actually enter into a
relationship and the girl don't actually
like him but he likes him for the
resources that he can provide for her is
that what you're suffering I didn't say
that okay so why don't you have a
girlfriend like a problem I didn't say
that why haven't you owned the girl that
you're having complicated I said it's
complicated why have you not owned it
yet I'm 22. okay I'm 21.
I
need focus on myself and Chase myself so
I ain't got no time you know I expect
that if you need to hustle you obviously
need time for yourself too that's fair
enough but for me obviously I said I'm
in a relationship and um
I mean I know what he wants like I cook
for him all the time I clean his fat and
things like that and I'm not like I
would not do it all the time but I would
do it because I know he needs some help
too in this flat you know I don't
actually live there but I'm always with
her sorry can you hear me sorry yeah so
I know his needs
I've been with him for nearly a year I'm
just doing what I think that would be
great for our relationship and he is
also trying his best marriage material
yes
now there was a hesitation there and
also from what you said before because
you never know
if you want to like in general do you
want to have like a long-term partner a
long-term companion I mean everyone I
think everyone would want that yeah of
course if if it wasn't for the how my
situation was I would have had three
three children by now I want to be
married do you not have any children no
and I'm very grateful because this is
the reason why also a lot of women
choose the lonely past because what I
know this because my mom has had
experiences I'm a I'm a I'm a child of a
complicated home I love my daddy was
amazing but as a man to my to my mom
there was complications and I understand
that if you fall in love with the wrong
man and you put yourself in this sort of
situations things can really go wrong
for you and you as the caretakers the
mother
all of that trauma that your child is
going to take is going to be you that's
going to witness it's going to be you
that's gonna have to take care of it's
going to be you that's going to suffer
through your child because you're the
mother so that's also one of the reasons
why women are really afraid we can't
just blame women and say that women
attracted but they shouldn't be afraid
because women leave they leave 70 to 80
percent of the time if they're college
educated they leave 90 of the time women
are the ones that are leaving okay and
I'll explain now we can say women leave
fine out of those 90 people in the UK 7
64 okay even the 64 now we can look at
the numbers and say oh that's alarming
okay but out of the 64 the women that
college educated why did they leave what
was the situation because it's really
this is a really common tactic it's like
whenever we hold women accountable for
something where there's always an excuse
no self-defense he's not an experience
it's not it's it is okay I'll explain to
you it's like you're breaking up a home
that's that's breaking the fabric of
society it's the worst thing you can do
to your kid is you put them in a single
parent household and we're saying well
but why did she do it doesn't matter
what's worse single parent household or
household size talk second abuse where
you grow up seeing for example parents
fantastic so why are you now saying that
the majority of the reasons why women
are leaving is because they're from
toxic and abusive households I'm just
trying to bring to the table the fact
that numbers don't speak the whole
answer is question yesterday is that
what you're saying because that's what
you're implying no I'm not implying I'm
just trying because I want people to
understand that generalizations do not
work because in every single statistic
there's more specifications within it
the same way that the same way that
we're saying women nowadays do this
women nowadays that which women which
number we are modern women but I'm a
modern woman but a lot of the things
you're saying we do we do know the
reasons because they they tell you why
they filed for divorce and the number
one is financial and one of the number
one reasons because one of the number
one reasons that women leave is they
start to out earn their husband and
you're right maybe he's not providing
but that's pretty freaking selfish when
you have a child because if you have
children it's not about you it's about
your kids happiness and that's the
problem is I'll have single mother after
single mother not you guys personally
again but on my show where they'll say
oh I left because I wasn't happy right
left because and that's the problem with
modern women is it's me me me me before
anybody else and when we make poor
decisions there's always an excuse and
that's why you know what that's shitty
we should probably be better that's why
I asked before when does the man's
happiness come into a relationship for a
woman because when as men what we hear
when it when we hear women speak a lot
like as Pearl does the show four four
times a week I I speak to women all the
time I do this show right and a lot of
the time when we listen to women speak
it's all me me me and it's like well
when does your man's happiness come into
the equation when do you say okay cool
it's not about me and it's actually
about me trying to make somebody else
happy because you have to understand men
are actually men have an inbuilt thing
when they get a woman to make them happy
it's in Bill do you know what I mean
like when men get with the woman is that
old you know what I want to take her
there and this makes her happy and this
she likes this women don't tend to have
that they tend to say make me happy
actually
I've done things gestures things for my
all the time like even like let's say he
just finished the competition because he
does parkour in America he does Park all
over the world okay
um we've just finished and stuff and
then he came back to the UK I surprised
him with a picnic and stuff like that
like I do think what he wants I don't
think it's okay to generalize is that
okay can I can I have a question and is
it picnics would you say that's more
something men would like or women would
like I think
picnic is actually I know he loves that
he does think he even said it to me like
before because we broke up once and he
said to me I I the only reason why I
actually did picnic because he
specifically said to me I just want you
to be at least like this kind of girl
that kind of you know go to pick with me
read books you know have some fruits all
these cute things together so that's
actually the reason why I took him to
picnic because he said so well I think a
lot of the time men cap in relationships
right I think a lot of the time men say
the things that they think women want to
hear but then
this is a personal thing I don't know
you personally but like every time and
I've talked to so many women every time
a girl does something for a guy it
always is on the side of what girls
would like what girls would like I'm
sorry no no I I've never I've never ever
okay again I do this four times a week
and I ask a lot of the same questions
four times a week so this is awesome
don't let me let me let me let me finish
it but you can go so I asked the same
question four times a week for six
months do you know how many people I've
talked to in six months no that's 35 but
I'm saying every time I ask a girl this
question it is always something that the
woman would want and never did you buy
him one
and I'm not saying every single woman
but I'm saying to me that indicates
something about women as a whole yeah
hang on did you buy him
generally let me say not never generally
when women say they've done something
for their man right yeah I'm saying a
man likes that like he likes picnics and
walks in the park no you're not men like
you know men like track days they want
to race a Ferrari like they want to go
and play football
as well because he wanted to do that and
I totally agreed I was like okay we went
and he does parkour and I said okay
let's go out and train parkour too and
it sounds like an active dude yeah he's
active and I really like that he's very
ambitious he's got a lot to offer and I
know I do have to because that's what I
said every time I go to him visit him I
cook for him I clean for him I do things
that he loves and he does the same thing
to me too and I think it should be like
that in a relationship I think if you're
listening to your man then it's easy
like for me I feel like I have a lot of
feminine energy but at the same time
it's easy for me to do nice things for
my man so for example if we're out
walking and there's something in the
shop that he sees and he's like oh
that's really nice then I'll remember
that but I also want the same thing
though yeah but you see the problem the
problem with modern females is let's say
they do something for a man
a majority of cases they do something
because they expect something so let me
give you example let's say you gave him
Tommy for his birthday something big and
expensive and he just gives you a
birthday card majority of the time the
woman is going to be like I gave you
this and it cost me this and this is
what you're giving me so so how would
you feel was a man if you also gave some
expensive back to your girl
answer the question how would you feel
how would you feel you had my question
repeat the question repeat the question
you make sense sorry repeat the question
you didn't allow me to speak sir I said
how would you feel if you brought your
girl some 20 grand back or anything that
is so expensive and then she just gave
your card how would you feel wait let me
answer the question
okay
goodness gracious all right number one I
would never do that [ __ ] number two
if I number two let's say let's say you
did that yeah hey well major of the time
guys that do do that is like the Sims
but let's say you do that because your
woman is treating you nice nurturing
submissive woman you do that in an
intention because she deserves she
earned that [ __ ] so even if she gives
you a card you don't give a [ __ ] you
don't give a damn because you don't
expect that [ __ ] back it's just you just
expect well and and matter you're used
to it you guys take girls on nice dates
all the time
and if you expect sex then you're a
misogynist let me ask you a question
then you work hard nine to five you wake
up maybe six a.m because you're also
commuting you work your ass off yeah you
do all of this to provide your woman
with a home right any woman will not
even cook for you or give you a massage
she won't even help you do anything with
your shirt before you go to work she's
just there enjoying life she don't care
about what you do for she doesn't show
back she won't be there exactly so how
is it that you expected woman yeah to do
things for men and then the men don't
don't even reciprocate it's not about
things what do you mean the pacifically
I don't I don't expect women no no
thanks for men that don't reciprocate I
expect women to pick good men exactly
and that's the same way that men should
pick good women I agree and that's why I
say there's difference between men and
boys and girls and women men and women
yes men and girls
the problem the problem is that modern
women the majority of modern women are
good wives and I can tell you this how
many how many of you are virgins yeah
but you don't you don't want to be a
president okay
okay this is like the first one of all
of my shows how many how many of you
have a cookbook I don't need a cookbook
I know how to cook exactly traditional
wife
I'm very creative
I'm 20. but may I just say something
quickly yeah um I think what you said
when you were talking about when is a
man's happiness prioritized I think a
difference that we should point out is
you said that men you know they provide
and they protect that's consistent yes
and as much as I agree with you I think
you know you should do like grand
gestures like picnics and you know give
them a massage and you know like listen
to what he says maybe pick something out
of the store from him I think it's
important to also show that consistency
of what he wants right I didn't get the
chance to say this earlier but I'm
really sorry uh the lady at the end that
you had to go through an abusive
relationship
yeah but it's not a fun experience but I
think
the fundamental concept of submission at
least in my faith is that a man and a
woman are equal in value but they offer
different things and if I'm in a home I
agree and I and I have chosen my future
husband I Look to Him to make to make
decisions how many of you have gone on a
date and a guy's like yo want to go out
Friday night you need to just plan the
date and I'll take you out it's not
masculine right like you want someone
that makes decisions and if you marry
them that's what you that's what you
want
um but you you do need to choose
somebody that in which you trust their
intellectual Integrity
um so and also just to make men happy
just if a man likes you to wear your
hair a certain way wear it there's no
harm in that if he likes it if I don't
like it but if you're not also miss a
woman then these if if you don't like it
but you're only going let's just say
you're going out and you want to wear
your hair a certain way okay okay fine
wear it the way you'd like but if you're
in the home and he's just chilling
watching TV and he looks over to see you
why not wear it yeah you know hang on
you know you said what if you don't like
it do you know how it is to be a man do
you know how many you know how much [ __ ]
we don't like that we have to do when
we've got a woman do you know how much
do you deal with like shopping like
there's someone love shopping he takes
me to shopping as soon as we get to um
Auburn Outfitters yeah as soon as we get
in he goes to his section straight does
he want to shop with you does he want to
go around the stove with you no no I'm
saying I'm saying does he want to go
around the store have you tried on all
of these outfits have you go into the
dressing room come out all the time I've
got this no I didn't go into the
dressing room about 500 different
dresses I don't do that I'm really easy
with shopping so do you know what can I
just tell you something and this is what
I think is the biggest problem that
we're having in general is the fact that
we stereotype everything the same women
the same way women stereotype men is the
same way men stereotype women like I
it's incredible because I sit here
sometimes when I hear what people say
about women and I know because all of my
friends are similar to how I am I like
football I don't want to meet them
Single Ladies Club it's not single
ladies club actually and realistically
we're all women that have been in
long-term relationships that
unfortunately ended for very very
serious reasons actually hang on are you
saying that yes your women friends
relationships have ended for the similar
reasons that yours ended literally
particularly the same type of guys wait
wait let me ask a question because I
want to probe that a little bit so what
does it say about the way you and your
your female friends I've thought about
this and there's there's two things I
take accountability for my poor choices
and I also take accounts and I also look
at the fact that Modern Men as well have
their own issues the same way modern
women have their issues a lot of modern
men nowadays actually don't even believe
in being the providing the protector
because they've become those are
classified as the bad boys wait exactly
and that's why I tell you there's a
difference between women and there's a
difference between your children can I
can I ask you a question did any of your
friends press charges that's the thing
I'll tell you what did it yeah can you
answer the questions
so this is important so so and this is
part so how do how do we know how do we
know what they're telling is true I'll
tell you I'll tell you why and this is
important when you are a woman of color
when you're a black woman and you're
dating a black man the first thing you
remember is that actually being a black
man in this world is completely
different so uh listen this is how are
you bringing color into this world
because it's important
I say you know when someone punches you
in your face you're not care whether
they're black or white
let me tell you if you punch you in the
face and in the Bible because you're
liking me you're just gonna accept it
because I understand because when we
want to look into things and understand
the problem and the root of it we need
to go deeper than just
three top layers there's a lot more a
lot of women especially now I also do my
own research and I also speak to a lot
of women because they approach me
because they understand they can see my
eyes I've gone through things and one
thing that I understand is a lot of
women want to protect their man because
as much as they abuse them the same man
that punch them in their face in this is
the thing women want to protect the guys
allow me to finish I'll explain to you
yes yes because when you love
you say relationships the same way that
men are victims of domestic abuse
because they are too afraid to speak up
and say a woman is beating me it's the
same way that a woman actually will
protect a man a lot of the time because
she doesn't want him to get in trouble
because
this is not different because when a guy
says a woman is beat you look like a
[ __ ] exactly and when a woman and if
you call the police what's the police
gonna do the police are just gonna look
at you like so you don't report it if
you do report it please take on this
[ __ ] but if a woman would put the inside
joke the guy goes into jail exactly and
do you want the man that you love to go
to jail I don't want the man that I love
to go to jail no matter nobody because I
don't want to protect him
yeah men get four times the amount of
sentencing for the same crime as a woman
there's actually cases where a man has
called the police and the police shot
the man who is being abused and do I
want that to happen no do you want that
to happen it's just because if a dude is
like this is the this is my problem I
don't know you personally but I I have a
problem with women that openly accuse a
man of doing something and you didn't
press charges like and so so because I
don't know you I don't know him how do
we know who's telling the truth and
that's why that's why the law comes in
and so then we we have where people on
this podcast they know your ex-boyfriend
like if you dated him for five years
where you're ruining a man's reputation
and nobody knows what's true because the
law didn't come in okay so then I'll
tell you something about the law when
you work your ass off as a man and you
have the law on your side because you're
a woman okay sometimes the law does no
it doesn't no woman women are literally
wait the law and relationships is
totally different the law and the
emotions is totally different do you
understand and that's what I think is
also important to know because the same
way a man works his ass off and then he
gets married and there's a divorce
there's no prenup and the woman takes
half of his money he's upset but the law
is there for a reason do you understand
I'm just proving the point that the law
that the law isn't fair on everybody
listen and that's what I'm trying to say
and the law is completely unfair to men
especially black men so me as a black
woman that understands the black
struggle I will never ever put a man in
that situation unless he's done
something
what I did instead let me flesh it out
so what you're saying is because
somebody's black and they're punching
you in the face you're not gonna call
the police on them because they're black
I'll explain something to you again
because I will tell you this I don't
give a damn what color you are you punch
me in the face the cops are coming okay
and this is what I'm trying to explain
to you and this is how I'm trying this
is because the bottom line is you
attacked me yeah yeah that's fantastic
and I get all of that and this is why we
then want to put things black and white
but there's always a gray area which is
the name of the show
and I'm trying to get there because this
is the thing I you you may have hurt me
you may have done terrible things to me
but I love you you are my man I don't
want harm to come to you because I'm a
nurturer I actually fall in love with
you I've taken care of you I've cooked
for you I've invested my emotions into
you which means you've punched me and
I'm going to sentence you to a whole
year in prison unfortunately I'm in the
situation that I mean I don't actually
want to see that to happen Okay so what
did I punch you again if and that's how
people get into it and then what if they
punch you again listen and that's how
people get into really seriously right
so so a man's punch you three four five
six seven eight times right and not want
to be called the police and not once you
think you know what this prob this
person probably deserves jail so what
you're gonna do instead what you're
gonna do instead is that you're gonna
have the person who consistently and
continuously punches you in your face
living in your own home okay and this is
that's what you're gonna do and this is
why I'm gonna now bring it back to the
old traditions and why actually people
stayed in relationships probably for
long and stayed married until the end of
their lives because actually men were
quite abusive back in the day mentally
they're women like no it's true a man
beating a woman back in the day was not
a problem
let me tell you let me tell you I know
this because I know my granddad used to
be my my your Granddaddy's your granddad
is not enough information listen in
African culture especially this is the
norm and I don't have to go for
statistics because I'm a black woman and
I I know I live I know victimhood
mentality listen no no wait let me
finish and tell you so back in the day
even there was a does an American show
that even they take the piss out of him
in American Family Guy where they says
pow write in the kisser which is the man
in the TV on TV back in the 20s or 30s
or whatever and the joke was that he
used to punch his wife whenever she took
rubbish right because domestic violence
against a woman back in there was
actually a little bit more acceptable
and less founded upon against uh wait
because because actually a woman is
meant to be my property so we wait in
which women paint men no no no it's
amazing to me as a man I'm just asking
you to wear your pain in the way because
what you're basically saying because
there's no statistical data for what
you're saying first of all there's no
questions
if we were to go back to I don't know
what what year like frame are you
talking about right now right what time
frame are you talking about generally
like from even my mom's generation so
what special culturally success
so if you have statistical data from the
70s to show what
domestic violence was like back then
then I would hear you out but the way
you're paying men is is because when
you're talking you're talking as if the
majority of men in the 1970s were just
coming home and beating their wives no
no right because that's that's what it
sounds like
give you guys a data point that people
don't really talk about yeah um so the
majority of domestic abuse situations
they're punching each other so a lot of
times girls will say like oh I was in an
abusive relationship but if you're
hitting back you're both hitting each
other like that's that's Mutual abuse
yeah yeah it's okay okay
let me finish so and the thing is we
have this perception that men beat women
more than women beat men but it's not
true women beat men when it's one-sided
abuse women beat men 70 of the time cool
where it's it's only 30 percent so I I
think so so this like narrative this
narrative where it's like women are
being abused and always have been abused
throughout all of history it's not true
no women women were protected throughout
all of history like men had to go to
Wars they always were protecting women
they're I'm sure there were one-off
situations
at any point in time did the two of you
have a physical education of course
because when somebody's been causing me
so which means
but no but what I'm trying to explain
let me tell you something yeah so you
were also an abuser let me ask you well
I would be because I'm defending myself
in self-defense if I was to take all of
this evidence to court actually I would
win okay so if I chose not to do that
though but no because after a while
somebody's hitting me I still love him
but you're you're doing things to me I'm
going to defend myself okay but you're
hitting him though of course because so
if a girl is hitting me let's say a girl
punches me bro and a guy punches the
girl back that's off the fence that's
not going to be looking at self-defense
let me tell you something yeah I'll
explain going back going back going back
to our saying first of all I'm trying to
to bring to the table that women being
lonely and they're being issues with
within relationships between men and
women is not just because women are more
than women now are this there's so many
other factors that we're not even
factoring in and we generally amazing
women like for example the fact that
back in the day people would stay
marriages for longer and they were
marrying if they were getting married
more because back in the day certain
things were more acceptable no no one
day a woman did you see the society back
in the day women had to chase men women
were basically the properties of men
things were traditional hence why
relationships were more longer okay and
this is what I'm saying and there are
consequences and things were traditional
and that is why a lot of women stayed in
and happy marriage is that's why a lot
of women were abused as well and that's
why the statistics will not show that
these women yeah they were married
forever but they were completely unhappy
and they were abused which I'm what I'm
trying to say is that not every single
person that is married is in a good
marriage the the men and women being
together is not just because
um they need to stay together and
everything is happy no women are lonely
now also down to their trauma also down
to the fact that modern men are not also
great down to the fact that modern women
as well are also not great but within
all of that there's too many different
subcategories that we are not thinking
about and we we judge and we point
fingers I will point fingers at women
because I know we're slacking in
somewhere in different ways the fact
that sometimes where you feel entitled
because oh I went to UNI and I'm
somebody no I understand you when genius
great congratulations but that doesn't
make you have more or less than anything
you just went you're here talking about
you got three degrees and I'll tell you
right and do you know why I say that
because the reason why I'm happy that I
got is because like I said I proved to
myself that if I work hard I can get
results so my mental power has increased
yeah we don't give a [ __ ] but you should
give a [ __ ] no why should I do you know
why I do [ __ ] no do you know why you
should give it [ __ ] because when your
children are in school and they need
support from the parent and you're out
there working it's going to be me that's
going to happen are you going to be the
teacher
when a kid when a kid comes to me says
Mommy I need help with the homework
Daddy's at work who's going to help
mommy so I shall clap for you that if my
kid comes
I just have a question why do you keep
what you should want no I'm not saying
no no like I'm basically I'm just being
honest I'm using the words that are
coming out of your mouth like I'm just
I'm just repeating what you're saying
back to you I'm listening yeah and and
you're telling them what they should
want because they said we don't care and
then you defend it so so you're telling
men what they should okay wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait just just
hang on just take what she just said
anyway I'll go back and then explain the
reason why I'm not telling because
they're different there's a difference
between wants and needs what men want a
lot of the time sometimes it doesn't
even make sense because what your life
is going to turn out to be doesn't work
with what what it is that you want so
that for example
how do you know the reason why how do
you I just have a question how do you
know I'll tell you this because he's
telling me but what so is your kids
gonna gonna are you gonna be the teacher
to your kid yeah I'm gonna be a teacher
to my kids I don't mean [ __ ] oh it does
mean [ __ ] you know what it means it
means that actually under pressure and
under really really in the situation
where I have to multitask a lot and stay
focused with the task at hand and
maintain my life maintain my social life
and take care of somebody I can do it
because I did it whilst I was in
relationships and in difficult
situations so my journey to get to the
end result is what I carry let me let me
switch it's something as well because
it's a good situation everyone's want a
qualification then what ladies let me
ask you a question right
would you prefer to be rich
and alone
or would you prefer
to be to have an average income and have
a husband and some children I'd rather
have a husband and childish husband and
children as long as that's the genuine
thing and it's no [ __ ] it's gonna
last forever yeah
that's it and I'm not going to leave and
it's me until the day because what is to
what is taught to a lot of women
nowadays in this generation right is
that you've got to secure the bag
get your money while you're young do all
do all of this and a lot of the time
um
money takes precedent to a lot of for a
lot of modern women right and so I
remember watching something that Andrew
Tate said people can love him or hate
him right and he said he was in a room
with his grandma and his grandma had a
certain amount of
um his grandma had a certain amount of
children and then those children had
children and those children had children
and he sat back and he looked at these I
don't know 50 people
that came from his grandma
and no one asked her about her Gucci
bags no one asked her about her her
Birkin bags no one cared about if she
drove a Rolls-Royce wherever she drove a
Range Rover right and so the thing is
for me what is being pushed to women
which is part of the whole reason why
they're lonely is to chase something
that's actually not going to give you
companionship
do you know what I mean
so
if that is what is pushed and women are
consuming it there must be consumers to
take it
yeah to an extent but not every woman I
I I think then why are 50 of women that
hit 30 single and child exactly and that
is not just because they're 80 all over
the world listen no way stop stop 40
seconds one person at a time and in the
west I'll tell you why because there is
that that percentage out of this 50
that's the category of the women that
are trash there's the category of women
that potentially have been with partners
that have abused them there's women that
have riddled with insecurities because
modern society makes them feel ugly and
unworthy there's too many reasons to ask
you guys okay
how many guys
you guys are all you're pretty girls you
have your pick of the lyrics
stop I'm saying like you have your pick
of the litter you guys that 21 22 could
pick a nice guy that you could get
married to and so it's it's on you if
you're 50 if you're 30 single and
childless you're there bad at picking
men it's like that's on you
why do they have to be always on the
woman because this is the thing like
like why can't we just take
accountability for our decisions
now you say it takes two to tango but
let's keep it 100.
who's the person that's opening their
legs is it the guy or is it the girl so
okay let me tell you something my friend
I get into a relationship with
and then one day you grow into something
because at the end of the day people
grow and they change constantly change
is constant for sure and two years down
the line you actually feel different
because it's just life okay somebody
that you connect with more and you don't
want to be with me anymore and you leave
me I've tried my best and I want to be
with you but actually I'm not your soul
mate you found your soulmate and you
left me okay you're saying how is that
my fault you're saying make you feel
love whoever [ __ ] but let's keep it
real you girls like the bad boys and
these boys don't even make my attention
not everyone but modern females strictly
do and they not strictly either yes they
do because if they do they wouldn't like
around the 19 to 25 they would like give
more attention to the nice guys you guys
don't think think that there's a group
of women that enjoy chasing after the
Futures and the Drakes of the world okay
that's the best thing is that there's a
group of women it's not women in general
when we say modern women that is who
we're talking about the the Sierras of
the world okay how many people are you
Sierra how many you how many people use
Sierra as an example of a single mother
where it turned out okay
for every one Sierra there's a hundred
girls that that doesn't happen for and
they're done those are the correct
thousands is that the correct definition
of a modern woman or is that just what
we're going with today because I
wouldn't say that's the correct
definition or if that's how you are so
what's your definition of a modern woman
I think somebody you know how you get
the whole Beyonce independent woman I
don't basically I think everything that
you would put in the category of a
modern woman but not just looking for
the bad boy not just this I think with
more depth to her do you know what do
you mean more depth I think the Modern
Woman you know who's a good example of a
modern woman now I think Rihanna is a
good example somebody that hustling
found her love and she settled down on
that love and her and her man are doing
projects together they're working
together now they have a baby
let me tell you something though he's a
bad boy he has a crowd here the stairs
and he's the 10 percent Ally okay but
that's because she's the one percent
would you like would you like but so you
use you used Rihanna right but for every
girl that tries to be Rihanna and tries
to lock down that guy there's a million
that don't and so there's a million
unsuccessful Rihanna
and so she she she's in the top what 10
of Beauty in her prime you know she's
over 30 now so sleep let's drop her down
a point but like like in general to
Rihanna's level ASAP Rocky is here
actually and that's what it is because
Rihanna is the superstar Rihanna is but
men don't care about that I know but I'm
just saying an example of a beautiful
powerful rich woman who actually went
for somebody that she fell in love with
and for her he's the right guy whether
he's rich or not
again she doesn't really matter
she's lucky she's that beautiful because
outside of that she doesn't generally
have what men want Purity and youth she
was known for giving like like there was
some national headline of her giving
some dude an STD okay and so and and so
she's not pure and then she's old she's
she's like 32 or something okay measured
on success and women are measured on age
[ __ ] yeah and so that's what's that
wow it's not it's not fun I'm not I
don't like it's not fun that's why
Linda's winning right now but can I just
say something at the end of the day now
we can judge and say oh this stuff but
then not at the end of the day is if
she's got a kid with this guy they
probably will get married if they
haven't already got married in secret
they can actually live happily ever
after because what it and I don't know
what the ins and out of their
relationships are but judging for more I
can see and giving the past that she's
hiding the man that she has found he's
somebody that respects her clearly
somebody that they that she trusts and
he trusts because they're collaborating
a lot and I'm sure she would not have a
baby
and again
that was rumors and so all I'm trying to
say is that do you really think ASAP
Rocky is faithful like did you know you
never know not every single rapper
listen listen a bad boy asap rookie
isn't faithful she's probably still
going to be even because she's the type
of man if we look at her past dating
issue Chris Brown Drake all these men
what did they all having like in common
they're always like a different type of
foods but maybe the reason why she's
staying with him fully and having a baby
with him it's because he might be he's
the one for her
the modern women you gave an example of
is like still doing the same [ __ ] no
right like even the example you guys
gave like that's a perfect example
myself as a modern woman but I don't
think I'm the kind of modern women no
see what she's talking about is a mother
woman that acts as substance let's keep
it 100 the mother woman that don't have
substance believe they're like the top
prize or like Vienna and they feel
entitled to certain behaviors
let me tell you something let me tell
you something like
a staple of the modern woman right they
believe that they are higher than their
level right so I've always said you see
when you take your makeup off and your
lashes off and your nails off and your
wig off and your hair inches out and
then you go to bed that's what you are
that's your level okay
I feel like I always get this though
yeah hang on hang on hang on
like you're higher than your level
because you put makeup on and weave in
and Nails on
wait wait wait wait wait wait what do
you mean
a lot of modern women tend to think that
because how they look after they've made
up that's their level no my dear because
of the bottom line is when a man goes to
bed with you you've gone back down to
that level and that is what he's seeing
on a daily basis when you're walking
around the house that's what you're
seeing so don't act
like you're a 10 when you're uh
and at carnival and at carnival when I
was asking I went around I said rate
yourself one to ten
ten I'm a ten I'm a 10 I'm a ten bro
you're like a five you're average Loser
yeah but can I set an insult those
[ __ ] is it not okay to set to be
confident though no no no but it's not
okay it's not okay to lie to yourself
but let's keep it 100 you see the makeup
the wick is off it's all a must it's a
must I personally believe that when
girls are have makeup when you approach
them they have a different personalities
if you approach them when you're
approaching without makeup they tend to
be more portable more talkable more have
more of a Vibe but when you approach
them when they have makeup they're all
like I'm this [ __ ] I'm this [ __ ] but why
are you hold on my makeup as well when
actually men in
makeup is fine but
women
they will spend two hours on their home
do you know what I'm saying and they
will look totally different people
ladies we've all seen The Tick Tock
videos of women looking a certain way
doing her makeup
right okay so there are a lot of women
out there me Brandon uh what's your name
again bro Fury we don't need to do that
we are beautiful right but we look like
this all the time write yourself do you
look like now I'm gonna say the truth
because a lot of women like don't think
they tell me because of all these makeup
all these fake things but us men like I
think a lot of men in general they just
don't know their worth some some men are
naturally nines but they think they're
seven because I don't know yeah which is
the same with women as well you know
that's why a lot of even beautiful yeah
okay if I go up to a girl and I say
you're average they take it as an insult
even though most people are average yeah
yeah no I'm just like oh I say that all
the time you're very um forward about it
no maybe that's what makes them feel
like it's a bit of an insult do you
think you're average no okay do you
think you're average I think I'm all
right do you think you're probably
talking about looks or as a whole as a
whole okay so let's go on what men judge
you on so men are going to initiate
initial judge you before on before you
even open your mouth okay right men are
gonna judge you based on what you look
like aesthetically right out of the
world out of all the beautiful girls I'm
average okay
average or above average I think I think
I'm average okay one thing yeah so the
only person that said you were above
average or you're not average was you
yeah definitely I'll tell you why but
I'm beautiful I'll be the most beautiful
girl in the world I want to ask you
something make yourself from 10. okay
in what like just in invisible person I
give myself an 8.5 okay okay now okay
okay it's here that's nice but let's say
you we actually bring women that
actually 8.5 are you really gonna say
that you're 8.5 hang on yeah did you
quit yourself at 8.5 yeah
I would wait wait wait I see my face
I'll show you without makeup fantastic
so what celebrity
or person in the media would you also
rate at 8.5
that's the thing I feel like a lot of
people that are in the media they answer
the question they are rich they are come
on it's a question that requires
explanation because this is a deep
question
most people most people in the media
most people that are celebrities they
are what you call Rich hot where they
are not actually good looking where they
can waste their money and everything so
self-defense mechanism is a word salad
no but I'm just saying so there's not
really many people that say that Maya
drama she's beautiful
she's got natural look so you think you
are on the same level as my Jammer I
would say my Jammer probably is a bit
more because she's got more access
please like it's not even listen just be
real with yourself now behold yourself
it's okay to be a fight it's okay wait
wait I didn't say all five I'm giving
you a good example one calm that
everyone calm down what I'm going to do
is I'm going to make you accountable for
the words that come out of your mouth so
you said you were an 8.5 yes and you
said and I asked you what celebrity
within the media or whatever is would
you also class as an 8.5 should probably
be a nine maybe okay so give me a give
me someone who you think that you're on
the same level as
there's not many to be honest it's quite
hard to think you can't answer the
question because you cannot simply take
account to believe that you are not 8.5
no because if we do bring women that 8.5
around you you're gonna hide yourself
I'll tell you I'll tell you why because
I'll tell you why I don't need you know
what the term delusions of grandeur no
listen listen I'll tell you something
you would be hating if you tell me I'm
not a beautiful woman because I'll tell
you something I walk down there you're
beautiful
one at a time I'll tell you why I'm an
8.5 right and probably can do more one
one stopping some richer I'll definitely
Elevate now I'll tell you one I'm a
natural beauty number one you're a great
TV okay yeah well if you're laughing
you're hating okay no no continue
majority of girls like to like they've
they cover all the lies with the truth
easy the truth because let's keep it 100
yeah
maybe because uh tens or nines literally
approached you but you don't understand
they just want your kids you don't
really find you attractive like that
I'll tell you something every woman has
Gucci and then there's levels to this
[ __ ] I know I'm on the level okay now on
the 8.5 level yeah okay cool yeah I'm
not even sure let me let me let me ask
you let me ask you another question
yeah true do you think do you think
women yeah generally understand how to
differentiate yeah between attention
from men that says you're [ __ ] sexy
opposed to I want to make you my wife
100 yes no no but I'm saying do you
think women know how to differentiate
sometimes
it's a trainer hang on wait wait Linda
Linda go on I don't think so why
because
they they don't yeah because they a lot
of like a lot of women you know they
look for guys that are smooth that are
have game and guys know that sex is a
lot except a lot more accessible now
than it was in the past so they they
like I know of guys I I know some guy
friends that I probably shouldn't say
that I know that I associate with but
like they say that they'll go to bars
and they'll say they're a lawyer they're
a doctor and get in bed and then they're
actually just working at Walmart you
know so I think yeah I don't think they
differentiate it well I think women have
a very hard time differentiating
attention from men yeah I I think one of
the reasons why you may think you're an
8.5 is because you get a lot of
attention from him right but but the
attention that you're getting from men
is because they want to [ __ ] you I'm
just going to be realistic
let me tell you let me tell you
men are aesthetic creatures yeah let me
just try and give you some game about
men men are aesthetic creatures right we
will see a nice ass pretty face some
round tits right and we would say oh my
God that is attractive right and women
will feel that attention and be like oh
my God he thinks I'm attractive but he
thinks you're attractive because he
wants to [ __ ] you not because he wants
to make his wife yeah it's not because
he wants to make you make you the mother
of his children it's not because he
wants to put you inside his home and
keep you there for the rest of his life
it's because he wants to get into your
coochie yeah all right let me let me say
it you need to learn to differentiate
between the two you ask me about my
physical rating I said 8.5
and you and you said it's going to go up
when you get money but it doesn't it
doesn't matter if you have money because
you can't buy Youth and once you and
once you hit 30 you're down a point well
you see yeah
my surgery
that's the thing like like this is this
is Kylie Jenner looks scary she like
when you see her in person like that's
not attractive I'll tell you why money
is and a lot of times like women they
get the botox they get the fillers but
like men can see it like they see your
face moving weird you see you're 100 and
it signals to them that like you're
you're uh for fun instead of a wife okay
and so you could get the money you could
get the surgeries but you can't buy
youth you can't buy Purity so so are you
really in the top let me explain to you
because that's an assumption that I'm
going to use the money to to do surgery
and do things the reason why if I'm
Richard you know why I'll be hotter
because I put it hard to who to the
world no men and women I'll tell you why
let me explain to you why and I'll tell
you just one of the major problems that
you have listen do you know what money
buys money buys you time that means that
if I Rich ninety percent of your eggs
are gone that's okay but I'm talking
about why I talk about being hot right
if I got money I'm by myself time in the
sense that I don't have to do half of
the things that I would have had to do
before I'll have a nutritionist if I
want to oh it's fine okay let me finish
let me finish well let me finish because
it makes sense there's a calculation to
this if I got money I can buy and I can
get a nutritionist or Chef which means
my diet is going to be better which
means that my skin will look better
because I'm eating better quality food
and means that I'm eating the right food
I can go to the gym more means my body
how did you become this deluded
you know what a lot of the celebrities
that are out there that look amazing and
everybody think they're beautiful and
they're so hot and every man wants that
girl it just even if it's just fun
because we're talking about looks
because I said about being hot okay wait
let me reform what I said is being rich
hot because if you see a lot of these
celebrities when they're average people
they will just average when they're rich
they're high let me refrain let me
rephrase
if you get rich you become hotter no she
doesn't mean her wealth
all right fine but you said when you
become rich you'll become hotter right
no the rich I've been trying to make
that money can buy me she's she's saying
she would get a nutritionist
um
you are still going to be 30. yeah do
you understand you're still going to be
30. so let me I'm not trying to pit
women against each other right yeah but
we have Linda over here who's 20 and a
virgin yes and we have you right you've
you've been you've been an abusive
relationship you're 29 you've gone
through all this stuff and you're if you
if you say you're 8.5 let's just say you
and Linda are 8.5 right you're both at
8.5 who do you think men are going to
choose it depends no it doesn't depend
they're gonna go for the younger one
okay I want to say I want to say
something
wait you see I want to rephrase what he
said he said about old men giving uh
attention no no the beta simps that
those simps will give the average woman
or any woman attention by default
because they look at women as sexual
objects so you're literally gonna think
all that attention you're thinking oh
you know I'm paying but really it's
because the Sims just look at everything
any just the gender if you're female
they'll just start giving you attention
and this is another problem number one
it's naive to think that I rely on my
looks to get in any anything in any
situation with men no way my looks and
no okay okay
would you have gotten on the Castillo
dating show if you weren't pretty
um yeah okay I'll tell you something let
me tell you something my looks are my
secondary gift my first gift will be my
personality and the only reason why
we're speaking English
I'm so sorry
okay okay you you yes it would be naive
to think that I rely on my looks number
one number two it would be nice to think
that I'm sitting here trying to display
to you guys why I would want to be a
wife to you I don't want to be a wife if
I wanted to be your wife I wouldn't be
speaking to you differently because I
want you to be my man I don't have to to
be treated treating every single man
like he's my husband because he's a man
my husband I'm gonna cut you off okay no
no Sarah go ahead what
now because she could like you need to
give other people so what what I'm
trying to say is
you don't understand how you first of
all self-reflection and introspection is
a thing right and I'm all about
self-reflection introspection and for
this whole conversation that we've been
having today I don't think you've
understood the way you've come across I
really don't and the thing is I'm not a
psychologist I'm not a psychiatrist so
you can you can throw away what I'm
saying you can say whatever that guy's
talking [ __ ] right but
the way the things that are coming out
of your mouth are so contradictory to
the way you are acting it it is very it
is
it's a sight to behold I'm not gonna lie
like I've done this show for I've been
on your shelf what six months now from
that beginning right and I've no I'm not
gonna lie I've I've rarely met women
that have been that contradictory it's
not contradictory it's just simply that
you're not you're not understanding that
there's levels to this for example you
can pet me and it's Linda right yeah so
okay no no I'm not trying to pick you no
no I'll just give it an example I'm
going to give you another example and
this is why I say it depends she is
younger than me 10 years basically
because I'm 29. yeah she's a virgin I'm
not definitely right okay as a man who
do you think listen listen and this is
the problem why is age and why is
virginity something that makes you a
better wife and I'll tell you why this
is
so the reason is because the more sexual
partners you have the less chance you
have of being a happy marriage if you're
a virgin when you get married after 10
years they survey the women are you
happy in your marriage are you still
married you have an 80 chance of having
a happy marriage if you're a virgin when
you get married which is really smart
what like what that she is and the thing
is if you've slept with five or more
people which I think most men would pray
for nowadays right right pray for yeah
five or less and like it goes down to a
20 so if as a guy are you gonna pick the
girl that has an 80 chance or a 20
chance of being happy with you how about
them that have slept with
so the thing is the happiest marriages
are actually when they're both virgins
so there is so that is a little bit but
the thing is like men actually if they
take the guy that slept with like say
two people and ten people the guy that
slept with 10 people is happier in his
marriage than the guy that slept with
two so actually like marital happiness
goes up at some levels for when men have
slept with more people where women where
women it goes down drastically and can I
tell you why there is as a man yeah
because when men experience women
multiple women they get to understand
that a lot of the time women are kind of
the same right and so what a man is
looking for is a woman to differentiate
herself between all of the other women
that he's had so when he's got into that
relationship or that uh marriage he's
like I've already seen it I've I've
experienced all the women in the world I
totally am understand what it's all
about so what is it so the difference
between women and men right when a woman
has
you heard of an alpha Widow do you know
an alpha Widow is right so yeah you do
that have you all right would you agree
that most girls have an X that they
can't get over or like they talk about a
lot so like if you have a friend like
she'll be she'll talk about the One X
so a Twist to a certain extent okay
let's go ahead go ahead right so most
women who have had multiple men there's
that one guy in your history
that you know that you probably still
want to be with right you know that
because you've had that experience right
and so when you get into a marriage
you're still thinking about that guy
still has a tie to you and you still
have a tie to him The One That Got Away
The One That Got Away and that's right
and that like why do you think that Katy
Perry song took off
right like that was that was a national
hit because a lot of people relate it to
it they related to it so what the
difference between men and women is when
a man gets into relationship and plus a
woman wants a man with sexual experience
a woman does not want a man who doesn't
know what he's doing in the bedroom
isn't it
you don't want a man that's a virgin
that's like oh my God where's your
clitoris oh my God I don't know what I'm
doing you don't want that guy right but
a man would prefer to have a woman with
less sexual experience and teach her
as to what it is that he wants right you
guys that are active no of course not we
don't want a girl who's been ran through
by the house
can I ask you a question though okay so
let's talk about this because obviously
we're talking about a man's happiness
yeah uh she may be a virgin if she knows
nothing about man's happiness I'm not a
virgin I'm 30 but I know everything
about right okay
okay but even if you do know what men
are still gonna choose the younger one
because when you're 30 bro yeah okay let
me give a good example but here's the
difference
it is Gonna Last you at 30. don't you
don't bring anything more of value
you're you're you're more damaged your
looks are fading away so so and you've
exp you've actually said you're more
damage because you've been in abusive
relationship I wouldn't say that I'm
damaged and this is another problem that
I think people have you are damaged only
when you decide to not go and face the
traumas that you've had to deal with I
have actually dealt with a lot of terms
I understand what happened to me I'm
sitting here and I'm speaking this
passionately and powerfully because I
think that people are very wrong about
some of the cons the conceptions that
they have about women and what modern
woman is and what a woman wants and what
a man needs if by going what you're
saying yeah basically what you want out
of a woman is just a [ __ ] okay
what man is going to want to do with
that [ __ ] but you don't have to deal
with because I dealt with it I'm a
mature woman no but you're still going
to reflect that projector on the guy in
the relationship no but the thing is
when you're is when you're over
something talk about it
you sound like on a public podcast
saying like that this happened it
indicates to me you're not over it just
like you're insecure just like if a girl
is constantly talking about her ex she's
not over it but when she stops bringing
it up and you you forget how about a man
that keeps bringing his ex like in them
[Applause]
women like to talk about the guys that
with the red flag that did me this why
why are you not talking about the the
guys that treat you good of course you
don't because you don't give a [ __ ] no
no I'll tell you two things one the the
intention behind everything that you do
is important I didn't come here to do
anything other than to try and bring
light to the fact that their people are
being really miseducated and actually
pointing fingers at women because if we
go by numbers then we say women do this
the Modern Woman means this the woman
the model when it is this the model is
actually really frustrating because not
every woman is the same Modern Woman
No I know I know and this is what I'm
trying to explain to you I'm just here
but women just say men are trash they
don't even know
I don't even say that I don't say that
the reason why I even spoke about my
exes because again I'm using it as an
example for Education if I want to give
you an example of education for what a
good woman a good man is for a woman I
can talk to you about my angel ex
actually the ex I was so sweet bless him
he wasn't working he wasn't working the
time because he was studying but I was
working and you know what he did he used
to take my shoes off for me when I get
in the house I'm not with him do you
know why I'm not with him because he was
too nice no because his International
Visa ran out and we couldn't make it so
you would be with him I would be with
him you would be with him he's in
Nigeria it's a very complicated
situation so I know you move to be with
a man I don't know if I'll be able to
move to Nigeria because actually things
are really difficult it's not safe for
me and that's the thing so out of it
there's there's so many different
situations that's then this is what I'm
trying to say to people there's context
behind everything you can never just
point the finger don't you think like as
adults we can understand that there's
Nuance like that we're clearly not
talking about every woman yes but the
problem is we need to be able to specify
this no but we have the responsibility
to be specific I just think as adults
like we can gather it's not every single
person and so I think I think I think
it's a really unproductive conversation
is if we say something about in general
and they say but not all when we know
that that's a thing like even like when
I say what women say men are trash
you're like but not all women say that
but okay okay but we know that that so
what is the purpose of what you're doing
to point the single do you want the best
solution it's not to point the finger
it's to talk about how women have a hard
time holding each other accountable okay
and we never talk about our problems
without pointing the finger at men and
even in this conversation we say this is
an issue with women like it's always
[ __ ] do this but men do that I think
it's more of a well-known issue about
what women do rather than men I feel
like as a you think so yeah I do I think
it's a society we talk about there's
jokes of the modern women we have
conversations you don't think men are
trash
it's definitely pushed but I'm just
saying that I feel like the men are
trash is talking about women I think
that is more so
the situation and Umber and let's not no
I totally agree with that not all men
and he's definitely pushed into this
it's pushed that that's what men are
like no no even in this country
that's not what you think but it was
pushed right it is but I just personally
from what I see maybe we look at
different things maybe we do different
stuff but I feel like I see more stuff
about uh women but yeah but I agree that
obviously why don't you say even in this
conversation like there was they implied
that most men were abusive in the 50s
I'm gonna cut it and I'm gonna I'm gonna
literally take the words that you said
and cut it like
one of you said that like men were
abusive in the 50s
50s happiness rates were a lot
I were back then than they are now so
I'm just kind of putting two and two
together like women were way happier in
the 50s and it's steadily declined
throughout the decades
so if we'd like full circle they were
less lonely and they were more happy
women nowadays are more lonely and less
happy
so when we look at 1950s and we look at
2022
for the women
um said we I read the article earlier on
about
um the the way in which women are
becoming more lonely right I we we've
spoken about the statistics that say
50 of women over 30 are now you know
single and childless
you guys have said you think women are
more lonely
so all all of the data and the
statistics and even the the anecdotal
data like from your own lives is
actually saying that women are more
lonely and they are more unhappy yet and
still
the same rhetoric is being pushed out
and the same rhetoric is actually being
consumed by all of these women so
is that to your benefit or to your
detriment it's both I feel like what
women are facing these what women were
Faith what women are facing now is a
choice is either you're going to conform
to the toxicity that exists through it
being a man's world or are you going to
be alone well what do you mean toxicity
no no no I mean I mean I mean that in
the sense of is either you're going to
accept things that back in the day were
the norm or you're going to
say no I actually I actually don't mind
living in a man's world I don't mind his
phone it was likely invented by a man
this beautiful architecture in London
was built by a man and so I'm looking at
modernity looking at the unhappiness in
women of how lost people are and how
just miserable and lifeless everyone is
and I'm like I don't want anything to do
with this I I want to find a husband and
I want to like fulfill my husband and
have kids
scared of this kind of stuff because
this is something bothers me as well
about the fact that I am a bit older
and it does and you have a child as well
and I have a child so number one I don't
feel the pressure of being
um I'm 30 I don't feel the pressure of
needing to find a husband because my
time is ticking or whatever it is I've
already got my child if I find my
forever man and I would love to have a
family with him but I feel like I'm in a
slightly different category
um I'm not alone obviously lots of
people I like that are you single yeah
yeah I'm single okay
um so but I I get why you were saying
about people being scared of being
lonely and understand how it's not that
for you I'm not putting words in your
mouth but you were saying about
um the Modern Woman and the things that
you see now and how it's a man's world
and everything I understand how that
could be quite scary and you don't want
that you want you want to be happy I
just want to be happy that's all I want
to be like whether you know what you
know what it is like like what she's
saying is uh the opinion and thoughts of
an actual some massive traditional woman
but the reason why most women are
unhappy because of the ideology that
they've put in their heads and because
that ideologies you're shaping your
shape shaping your reality and the
society in a different way like in her
way she seemed like she's happy anyway
she's all calm but like let's say for
example for you you're looking at um
things differently you're looking at oh
if I'm a man's doing this I feel like I
have to do this I feel like I have to do
that but for her she feels like I have
to do it because I'm a submissive woman
that's a traditional woman so you know
so the thing is about the thing is um
your Dynamic you say you're 30 and
you've got a child right so that Dynamic
generally
because I speak to men a lot and a lot
of men say they don't want to get into a
relationship with a single mother yeah
that's fine do you get what I'm saying I
feel like when I meet the right person
it's not going to matter right okay I
hear that but what I'm saying is that
no no no no no you should be easy wait
wait I've had a lot of single mothers
speak as if they are the prize right so
and they would say oh just because I've
got like I come as a package
I'm not saying you I'm not saying you
right I'm not saying you so they're like
I'm a package deal you have to you know
take me and my child and I'm saying a
lot of the time when women speak like
that they don't understand how men think
because generally men if they're going
to take on your child they understand
they're taking on someone else's child
it's not their child you know I mean
they're
because I did it I know because I did it
do you know what I mean I did it for 10
years I took on someone else's childhood
I was a woman for 10 years right so I
took on a woman's child for 10 years
that wasn't mine we had a child
ourselves but I took on her child before
I took on mine right and one of the
things is that I understand as a man is
that when a man takes on another man's
child
that stepfather role
is not ideal for any man
do you know what I'm saying so I I
always say single and the thing is
single mothers don't like to hear it but
I tell single mothers
you are very lucky to find a man that's
going to take on you and your own and
that's fair enough and I don't think
people should get defensive at that yeah
I really don't I think it's
you just own your situation yeah I've
never introduced
um my child to a man I've never been
like when I'm trying to raise a man I'm
not trying to raise a boy oh he's a boy
no no I'm saying like for my son when
he's yeah
it's very important that he sees a very
happy healthy home I don't want to be
like oh this is Mommy's new boyfriend
right he's never seen me within with a
man because the only time that he will
is when I found a man that is I I know
that's my forever man right I see things
go wrong but you know yeah yeah and that
man needs to love my son more than he
loves me why wait wait
okay I want to say something I want to
say something on this you see the
problems
the problem with single mothers is they
expect a man to come and basically you
do your thing with another guy he's in
unconditional the baby daddy is still in
the in this in the in the scene you
expect another man to come and play
another person's story mode because
that's basically what he's doing and
come on what love but if if I'm if me
and you are in a relationship I'm in a
relationship with you no offense that's
that's a different thing because let's
keep it with 100 I mean when you
interview by the time that I introduce
him to my son this could take no no but
if the guy wants to be introduced to the
sun that's common so let me let me try
it let me try and give you let me try
and give you this as a man who's
actually done it and done it for like a
decade right I'm not doing it anymore
but I've done it for a decade when you
say things like he me he needs to love
my child more than he loves you hello
let me just tell you that's not gonna
happen okay I'm not even at the point
let me just tell you my son men do not
love children that are not theirs
biologically more than the woman that
they're in love with it doesn't happen
Okay so I'm I'm I'm just trying to give
you some game if you if you take it you
take it if you don't you don't
biologically though what about where
that go into everything without adopting
children and everything what happens in
nature when when there's a Cubs and and
even historically when they were would
take over the when they would take over
a tribe they would take the women kill
the children yes and and so many lions
do it men are programmed to be disgusted
by other men's kids like they can't undo
that they understand it with that but
the thing is the reason why I'm saying
this is because
you seem like a nice woman good woman
you know I mean I'm not I don't know
your life but I'm saying if you are
looking for a man
that mentality saying he needs to love
my child money loves me take take that
out yeah
okay so maybe not as clear-cut as that
but you understand the way that I'm
going no but one thing you need to
understand is because a man is going to
love you he's gonna love you but you're
trying to say that lovely if you want to
love me you need to love the whole
package and you know I think what she's
trying to say is through your love for
me you will have love for my child no
but having love for somebody doesn't
mean like you love them more than so for
example for the time being that you're
with me and that relationship is going I
actually if for us to work because it's
not only the man that makes the choice
for us do you have children I don't but
I understand what she's saying because I
come from a home where there's a lot of
like different uh there's some of my
aunts have got children with different
men
I come from a bit of a traumatized sort
of background Civil War and so on so
these things happen right and it's more
like through your love for me yeah
because you love me you will have love
for my child meaning that whilst you're
in the picture you can fulfill the image
that the role of being a man male figure
but you'll never be the dad and that is
why you could never love the challenge
also I had the um experience as well as
my mom's uh child I was I'm the owner
I'm the oldest
um I'm the only child from my mom and
dad and then my mom got married to
someone else right anyway he was very
abusive to me and my mom he wasn't and
um I don't think that obviously it
wasn't okay at all but my mom was just
taking everything that you know he was
doing because she was pregnant at that
time as well and um yeah like I know
where you're coming from when it comes
to um what's it called what did you say
again love about loving your childhood
yeah like I've never experienced that
I've never experienced that from my
mom's ex-husband he was just very
abusive to me and my mom what about your
father my father is he's lovely he's
never done anything he's never beaten me
up he's never done anything have you
guys watched this video of this guy that
uh gives his um his son McDonald's he's
on McDonald's yeah
yeah that's that's how it is you're
basically trying to say yeah let's say
for example you have other kids and he
don't know you're basically he should
provide for your other kids even though
you may be in a favor with your baby
daddies or whatever he should provide
and show equal love for let's say you
have a kid he should show equal love for
your son than his son can I tell you
something so let's go back so I want to
go back to her situation hold on one
second one time I want to go up with
your situation so your child does they
do they have their father in their life
no
and that's probably one of the reasons
why you said that and the reason yeah so
the situation obviously I don't want to
talk too much because this is there yeah
but
um there's no bad anything between right
our situation but because your son
doesn't have his actual father in his
life when you said oh he needs to love
my child more than loves me I'm just
saying
for me the ideal and every child every
child wants to know who their biological
parent is do you know what I'm saying
and they want a relationship with their
biological parent do not expect any man
to come into your life who loves you he
could love the ground that you walk on
right it doesn't necessarily mean he's
going to love your child the same man
it's probably not going to happen I'm
just letting you know as a man I
appreciate your opinion yeah like you're
saying you know how I asked you before
but we didn't touch on it like what
about like adoption you know what I mean
I don't want to talk about that and such
I'm just saying you said biologically
yeah no man is ever so what does that
mean for children that grow and care and
go to Fosters yeah I mean adoption like
is that is it that the same you're a
mother yourself yeah so you know what it
felt like to hold that child in your
womb right for all that that's an
experience that I as a man I could never
actually understand because it never
happened but you know what that's like
and you do you think you can love
another child who is not who never grew
inside
you can't do it
um
I'll give you a little example so I'm
one of um 10 kids and um actually we
have three that were adopted
um I'm adopted yeah yeah yeah
um
my grandma adopted me for a little while
I grew up at her as well my mum and dad
was totally they have their own families
and things like that so I grew up in a
you know very
um tradition like it's just different
way and I was like I mean my mom was
never okay because of like she got
married to someone else and things but
she I think she's very happy now she's
with someone else who lives in her house
he's very helpful and he loves the kids
I have three siblings and he totally
loves us like he jokes about and things
but he he's the best person that my mom
has like ever been and she's so much
happier now and I really like that go on
continue
um so one of my brothers was actually on
my parents my dad um knocked up my mom
when she was a freshman in college and
they gave up that kid for adoption okay
um and so I didn't know he existed until
I was 22. and now we have a relationship
with him he we like hang out we do like
the family functions and he hangs out
more with his biological family now
probably than his adopted family okay
and I don't know what it is but there's
just something with being like
biologically related to people yes that
even if we like we grew up in completely
different like he grew up middle class
rural Wisconsin we we grew up you know
very nice like Chicagoland suburbs and
even when we were in completely
different places like there's something
you can't buy with that and understand
what you mean yeah yeah for me um I have
a really so basically I found my
biological mom
um six years ago and we've got a really
great relationship my my family you know
my parents my my family that I've always
been there since I you know since that
brought me up they they're really
supportive everything's great like it's
like a fairy tale kind of thing yeah I'm
very very grateful but I don't feel like
I feel stronger towards my biological
um mum because she is my biological mum
like I just don't see it like that so I
don't know if that's just um like I'm
not denying or saying anything else I'm
just saying like I don't feel uh oh
that's really good you know what I mean
like I yeah yeah and I'm not saying you
can't like I understand what you're
saying
like obviously I just think it would be
hard for a guy to feel the same way
about an adopted kid as a biological kid
like you know I just don't I think it's
it's hard because man we can't undo
their wiring or like women because then
does that mean that my dad like um
doesn't feel the same way as my
biological dad would feel about me yes
do you see what I mean the thing is it
is for me it's the same thing when
parents say they don't have favorites it
is yeah they do
yeah people are going to be brutally
honest okay yeah that's why I get
worried about having another child
because how can I love anyone but can I
tell you something yeah I'm scared no
but it's gonna it's gonna grow inside
you see yeah it's kind of grow inside
you so you're gonna love it but you know
what it is well he was mentioning about
the guide with the McDonald's and the
kids do you know why that's the problem
it's not because it's a requirement for
him to do that because he's with the
with the mom I feel the reason why I
would look at that and I say actually
there's something Dodges because
generosity generosity towards the child
is different you know I mean putting
creating that difference between these
children creating like that sort of
jealousy doesn't it's not healthy so you
expect Tim to come and play out it's
McDonald's most men wouldn't even give a
[ __ ] but this guy actually takes even
though personally I don't know why
bringing McDonald's okay I'm just gonna
do it let's say McDonald's let's say the
McDonald's is seven dollars okay and he
brings his kid McDonald's how many times
a week would you say three four it was
every day I believe oh every day
okay let's I think she worked with
something I'd say some days it was
something else okay so now so that's
fifty dollars so a week so now let's say
let's add into what she had three other
kids yeah there was three okay so that's
200 now yeah so now let's take that by
four that's 200 a week times four times
twelve that's ten Grand a year okay
I think that I think about this because
maybe like culturally my background kind
of requires you for to show more love to
people because we come from a lot of
suffering because I don't were you from
Angola yeah so Civil War it's dirty it's
ugly and a lot of people this thing of
adopting and having like extended family
that you bring in out of that struggle
because we are humans at the end of the
day and when you act with kindness
towards Humanity that's when I think
you're the most beautiful person if I'm
with a man and I have a child with him
and he brings my child with him
McDonald's every single day and every
single day that he never once not even
just that one time bring something for
the other children I'm just saying
actually do you know what why should he
be entitled to bring for other kids he's
not being entitled you can no it is no
let me tell you what
wait wait absolutely what obligations
is not obligation but for me is what it
reveals from you because a child is a
child I would help a child I would not
want the child to be singled out from
another so can I can I give you why
would you spend your own money on a
child that's not even yours because if I
I'm sorry I've been in that situation
that's what I'm saying and it doesn't
feel great it doesn't feel good
okay do you know how doesn't feel great
of course that's my mom as well
this is the reason why also why they
have split up because of me that's why
because he didn't accept me because I
was my mom's first child for someone
from someone else and um it was really
upsetting and it's traumatizing anyway
and I know where you're coming from also
like it's just not great for the kid and
for the mom but it's mostly for the kid
if I if for me if I see him buy food to
my siblings and he doesn't do the same
thing to me of course I'm gonna be upset
yeah but I think you're not
understanding that but you're not
they're not in a relationship you're
looking at it from from my point of view
you're looking at it from his point but
my mom also but my mom also wouldn't
feel great about this because look this
is my child too you know it's my one but
the thing is like your mom made a choice
right and so if she was a single mother
that was her choice that was her her
cross to bear so it's on her to figure
out a way to make you feel and she has
figured it no and I'm saying I'm saying
if if that was the case then your mom
has to buy McDonald's so he she thinks
it's coming from him because because
that's your time you know like that's
that's your that's the badge you made
and at some point like we have to take
accountability for the decisions the
thing is that it wasn't just even about
his um I don't know action but it's uh
his valuable things that he says to me
oh that's not my child why would I look
after that things like that or you go
back to your country you're not even
from England like things like this
is up here
actually it is it calls me certain
things that I don't want to hear and my
mom don't want to hear something so
you're saying that he's English yes okay
and you're and you're from where
Philippines Philip and your mom's
Filipino obviously yeah okay so and
that's all different Dynamics yes that's
a totally different story from obviously
from my experience yeah so this is what
I'm saying your mom has a racist husband
or something like that well he wasn't
like that from the beginning it's just
the the fact that when the kids grew up
obviously I grew up with them so they're
very lovely kids they're amazing they
look after so they have English and
you're the only full Filipino yes
but look at the the video you need to
understand the video they weren't
together he was just doing it for the
sake right they were married
can I tell you something this is the
thing let's put it down because I when I
look at people's actions I don't look at
it just for what it is on the surface
like for example if I go to if I have a
child then I go to the school and my
child is a privileged child and I see
every other kid and realistically they
know their parents don't do so well that
kind of suffering they see my kid I feel
out of the kindness of my heart and
knowing what children are liking knowing
their innocence I would feel bad as a
kind person to allow the students to see
my child eat and live their best life
and they're just saying that because
it's not their fault that they don't
have more so out of the kindness of my
heart and out of generosity this is not
out of responsibility and I have to I
have generosity and kindness I said you
know what today I'll bring extra sweets
for all the kids
you need to understand that he's doing
that every day
but then it's like with women we're just
so confusing because it's like okay well
how much does he have to do it if he
does it once will she be happy probably
no like then there's something else I
mean I get it you guys don't do it don't
do it for her like I'm just saying these
things reflect on who you are as a
person [ __ ] who you are man he's just
trying to trees
I get it of course a man is obviously
gonna treat his um biological kids
differently to a kid that it's not his
right and I totally get that because as
I've said I have experienced it and it
doesn't feel great and it's also not
okay but it doesn't like so why should
you project
it doesn't erase the hurt that you went
through yeah right but the thing is the
hurt that you went through is not the
man's problem the hurt that you went
through was down to your mother and
father splitting up that's the only
reason why you're going through that
hurt because your mother and father
never had that relationship right so
anything after that was going to be an
ism and a Schism right regardless of
what it was it was going to be ISM and a
Schism so when a guy that comes into
your mom's life and your mum's chosen to
take this guy on as a husband blah blah
blah she's taken him on understanding
his mindset and so if if his mindset was
to say you know what that child is not
mine right right
and your mother was okay with that then
you need to go and talk to your mother
yeah oh and you know what let me just
clarify as well what I said is based on
you and you have a new partner and your
partner is coming to be around you and
your other children are not his if you
are not together now this is when the
women need to take accountability Amanda
is not with you shouldn't be around the
children that are not his because if you
are if I if I was in that sort of
situation with the McDonald's person I
would just say oh my God I'm so stupid
because every time my man will stay my
son to McDonald's I'd be like son go
with your father I'll say with these two
then you come back and all is good I'm
not going to to allow that man to be in
an environment that he's not my man
number one anymore he's just the father
of one of my children to be around my
other children where he has absolutely
no no standing in my own home so why is
he around them
but you see the thing with modern female
they like to use their child to control
the guy so when they take when they take
the child
it's like they're kind of forcing okay
if you're not gonna if you're not gonna
you know they don't they don't really
want the child and the guy to deal with
the relief that have a strong
relationship because it's like if you're
not gonna be with me then you're not
having a kid so that's why they complain
or even though he's treating the kids
say oh [ __ ] that you need to treat
everyone because she's angry she's angry
at the fact that you know she can't
really get this guy in a relationship so
why should this guy be entitled to have
a relationship with his son go on hang
on wait Linda go on you will put your
hand up go on Linda so I think so in
your case right you're very you seem
very kind you seem very down to earth
unfortunately though when you have a kid
it does make it more difficult to find a
man yes ah absolutely I believe that if
a man were to date you he should you
know make the kid feel as comfortable as
possible and but if you had your own
biological kid it would be very it's
very unlikely and biologically
minute that he would love your kid that
you had with another man more than he
then more than his own biological child
yeah however
I do feel like not all hope is lost in
finding a man I think the way they were
talking to you could I could get you
down I just think with that with the
disadvantage that you do have I do feel
like Concepts like submission and
allowing a man to lead and take
initiative and you know prioritizing
things that he wants would would be very
beneficial to you because a lot of women
out here are not submissive at all and
like they they have no idea what men
look for so if you can kind of learn
what men look for I think it's
absolutely compromise I have a question
if you were today if you were to date a
man could he discipline your child
that's really interesting I think
um
number one it depends as well about
you're not you're not a mother about age
as well and it depends what you mean by
discipline so do you mean now so my
son's nine at the moment so so we're
talking about right now yeah so okay
he's gonna be a teenager soon so let's
say let's say you you find a good man
and we're obviously we're married
because otherwise he's not going to be
around myself okay okay yeah okay yeah
so you're dating seriously yeah and
remember like if if he's dating you
seriously he has to see what he's gonna
get in the marriage okay yeah and so
assuming that he's a good man you trust
his judgment would you allow him to
Discipline Your Child
um so what do you mean by discipline
Billy's ass okay number one I understand
cultures and stuff but I just discipline
I said that put him in his place like if
you're doing something stupid like um
like Hands-On have you
it doesn't have to be physical it can be
verbally disciplining your child or
punishing him like so he's talking back
you know like teenagers do boys like I
have brothers they'd be doing some wild
[ __ ] so okay your your boy is
disrespecting him absolutely he can
discipline in the ways that we've spoken
about previously obviously me and my
partner would have the conversation you
would have a conversation let me say
something when we get to know each other
because my son needs to respect the so
let me say something right father
I've done it for like a Whole Decade and
what I found is the mother of the child
that you're with will always let you
know that that child's not yours right
when it comes to discipline whether it
be a conscious or a subconscious thing
they'll always let you know that that
child's not yours
hang on hang on so if so if and when it
was time for me to discipline and that
child was getting a little bit too you
know a little bit
that would be that would be a a line of
discipline that I knew I couldn't cross
that her father because her father was
still in her life her father could cross
that line
but I couldn't right but for me as a man
of the household who protected and
provided for this household I feel like
I should be able to those children are
my children yeah I agree with you I do
able to discipline the children the way
I just my children and that is one of
the reasons again a lot of the reasons
why men
[Music]
stay straight and stay away from single
mothers because if a man is going to
become king or Emperor or head of the
household right he's going to want to
run that the way he wants to run it a
lot of the time the mother won't let him
know these are conversations that you
would have with yourself would you have
conversation with your biological father
and how he's going to discipline his
child that's why I take that's like
taking part of his masculinity no no you
wouldn't not with her but I don't think
anybody really like to and people talk
about all kinds of stuff before it
happens but in this situation I'm
bringing a man into not just my life so
therefore we will have these
conversations before because obviously
it's important so I have a question what
if there was a disagreement he
disciplined your kid in a way that you
didn't agree with what would you do as
long as it's not a physical put a
physical aside say it was physical just
say it was physical what would you do
then obviously I would have the
conversation that that's not okay
explain why that's not okay um would all
deal with it
yeah but see this is like it's like a
lack of submission because submission is
a mission is trusting a guy's judgment
yeah and like I'm not like you you
actually seem so nice I like you but
like it's like I feel like that that's
going to be hard for a guy because it's
like you have to pick and choose like
what he can't wait I know I completely
understand and agree with you on that
side but just for me with the physical
side I just feel like
um I wouldn't I just can't do it like
don't touch my child I wouldn't touch my
child so exactly so kind of in a way it
kind of so I don't you're kind of you're
kind of in a way saying that okay you
may be his uh stepson or whatever but
he's not yours so you already tell him
this ain't your problem
yeah but that's what I'm saying you
can't you can't yeah you can nurture it
but there's a line which means you're
kind of in a way you're controlling him
which means he's never gonna have real
love for that child because you cannot
really you know but that's totally
different though that's violence that's
totally no but okay I'm giving an
example like this remember remember I
said he's a good man and you trust his
job okay
sometimes a different like my dad hit my
brother maybe maybe he hits you a little
bit my dad's a great team my mom beat me
with a spoon
right you know what yeah yeah she would
hit me with it I deserved it
[Music]
I stole from my uncle and she came and
said you stole all right you know one
thing yeah I believe as well that let's
say uh the father hit the child and the
child is maybe uh 12 or 13 and if the
child kind of exaggerated or lie I
guarantee you the mother's gonna believe
the child over the father can I say
something what I wanted to go back to is
what you've done
without trying to do it because I like
to listen to people and a lot of the
time the subconscious mind comes out on
the conscious right you said my child
right so the fact that you call the
child your child he is going to know
that a child's not his right and I said
that honor if there was a biological as
well I think that is right so regardless
so you see this child as yours right and
so when somebody sees something as
theirs they act a certain way they they
behave in a certain way to let people
know that this is mine right this is it
so so this is one of the reasons why as
I said a lot of men
think nah Single mother's not because
they don't want to say
they don't want to go into a situation
where someone's saying it's mine you
know the children is mine you don't do
this mine I feel like I would be like
that regardless and maybe that's just a
reflection of my character that maybe
now you pointed out I can realize maybe
I shouldn't speak in certain ways rather
than because I'd be happy it's not even
about speaking if me and you had a child
together I would still probably
I've chosen to use that word right if I
need to be mindful on my words right
that's kind of a lie though because
let's let's
say you have a little kid like for you
as a woman you may smack him just a
little just a little there's you you
can't lie and say that you've never
touched your son just a little smack I
mean if she said okay she said she
hasn't she hasn't and let's say are you
from the farmers let's say the farmers
some people just don't smack their
children yeah yeah I mean must be nice
can I say something yeah no do you know
what this this side here I will say
actually baby girl you know I love you
right but I would say maybe because of
my African background the way we look
our respect and the way we look at
discipline is quite different when it's
an adult and there's a lack of respect
from a child the adult by Being the
adult by culture and I would say by
right can discipline that child and
discipline now is is this is what we're
not talking about there's discipline and
that is abuse and this is if there's
something that in your culture or that
in your personal in life in just how you
are that you don't agree with you can
discuss this early on and said you know
what at this point like educating the
children I'm really not I'm trying to
not be violent at all because I have
that experience or from what I believe
is just not right so when something
really grave happens can we please try
and think of a better way to handle it
than to hate the child if it gets to a
point where a good man hits your child
because they and for good man to hit
your child it takes a lot right it takes
a lot when it gets to that stage
actually it's not about my childhood so
that you need to get to the bottom of
the situation and understand what
happened and then you can can also
reinforce the fact that that child
needed to be disciplined because at the
end of the day this now comes down to
respect less than or this is my child
your child biological non-biological is
respect you know what I mean and I think
that discipline and respect is things
that are really important that actually
anyone should be able to do your kid
goes to school the school disciplines
your child your kid who's your teacher
who's the kids teacher yeah you teach
them in school and everything I love you
your teacher the teacher will tell the
child get out of my classroom you well
root you can go to detention stand there
and I feel like I can't really speak on
it too much because I haven't
experienced both sides I just have an
opinion on what I think and what I feel
and you know and that's it really so I'm
not saying that I'm like yeah right or
wrong in any way it's just my personal
life experience and I haven't you asked
me questions that I haven't found myself
in a situation so I can only sort of
think quickly I only I only ask because
it's just good to think about because
it's just like I've listened to me like
I've listened to men talk for so long
that I just understand like their point
of view on a lot of things and a lot of
them like it's not necessarily that they
wouldn't date single mothers um although
a lot wouldn't but like
a lot of it is like the problems that
come with it yeah like the baby daddy
like the the disciplining like like the
problems that Sarah was doing
well and the would you allow someone to
like legally adopt your child
um what you mean so they're legally
their father yeah because the other
issue is like men will take on someone
else's kid put a decade and then they
break up and yeah yeah absolutely it
would be something I'll be open to I
would never say no but obviously that's
a separate situation but I just wouldn't
say no okay yeah
um I think
I kind of wanted to close out the show
but Sarah he'll be back
um thank you guys for coming this week
thank you so much thank you for having
us oh can I just say something quickly
husband you know I'm only talking like
this to these guys because they're
saying rubbish about women but you know
you know family right here you are going
to be my husband I'll take care of you
good for you I'll give you a massage
I'll go watch football games well you're
going to be submissive though you're a
walking red flag
I'm only walking right now
Amanda isn't secure how would that make
sense because Amanda is insecure can
actually give the woman the time to sit
down and explain things and listen to
her the same way that woman that is
insecure men can't handle you no this is
numbers no do you know what because it's
true like seriously I I'm an African
woman first and foremost I'm an African
man
well you I this is introductory I If by
now you should notice that I speak an
introduction middle and conclusion right
I'm an African woman which means
actually culturally yes
because we talk about the topics if you
say things generalized actually a lot of
the time you miseducating the most
ignorant people that need the most
education you get so I feel like I talk
in words and he's going in that I'm an
African woman which means I've got
certain core values that are built and
that are there to ensure that you as a
woman you can be there for your man but
then at this same time I believe that we
need to revise the role of man and woman
because the Modern Woman has changed and
the amount the Modern Man Has Changed do
you go I mean you keep saying African
but in the African Traditional Values is
is literally in the in the the values of
in the African household for a woman to
literally be submissive 100 to a man
this is why I said now they need to be
revised
because
the same thing to a man because the
modern man has changed the modern man is
out there to bang bad things the mother
the mother man has changed because the
mother woman has changed of the
delusional ideology no no both have
changed
men are changing clothes of women one at
a time what you're saying when they're
they're out banging all these girls
that's not true let her having less sex
than ever the average guys don't even
have something when you say things that
aren't true it paints a narrative that's
not so real so let me tell you something
it's the same way that now we can say
the Modern Woman you know
a mother woman is lonely the modern the
modern it's based off of data modern
women are having more sex than ever yeah
while men are having less sorry they're
not having more sex than ever they're
having the same amount of sex while men
are having less so we're all sleeping
with the same guys where men are more
lonely the reason I say that women over
the age of 45 are more lonely that are
single and childless between the age of
between making money between 50 000 and
75 000 is because they they rate that
they are they say I am less happy so so
so so so that's based off of data okay
so the question now becomes you're going
to get a cat or a dog I don't need I've
got many men wanting to work just answer
the question again I'm gonna have one or
maybe three husbands I'm telling you
right now what never would be a ring
that's like me saying I deserve to be a
housewife the delusion is real if I
believe my needs a value if you if you
like if you had the men you wanted
interesting I'll have one husband let me
tell you what I want there you go listen
why do you know why I'm not in a
relationship right now because uh
because you crazy no because you know
it's a messy woman you know why I mean
you're not in a relationship right now
because you're crazy no it's only
because I'm enjoying Freedom that I
haven't had for five years actually in
the streets I'm in the streets and that
don't mean I'm [ __ ] people that means
that I'm out there I'm searching for
opportunity
honestly speaking if I click my fingers
like this I'll be in a relationship and
I'll make it last I made it last year
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible